Well, here we are. It's Will. I've Sean and Jason aren't here yet, but I just want to say don't be naughty on this all-new smart list. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
好了，我们开始吧。我是威尔。肖恩和杰森还没到，但我只想说，在这个全新的“聪明清单”节目里，大家可别调皮捣蛋。聪明。少点。聪明。少点。聪明。少点。聪明。少点。聪明。少点。聪明。少点。聪明。
Bless. You know what though, being in London, thank you. That's right, Matt, thanks everybody. Sean's got material. No, I don't. So listener, let's catch you up. Sean is in London doing another run of Goodnight Oscar.
天哪。不过你知道吗，在伦敦的感觉真好，谢谢。没错，马特，谢谢大家。肖恩有素材了。不，我没有。所以听众朋友们，让我们来给你们补补课。肖恩正在伦敦进行《晚安，奥斯卡》的又一轮演出。
What a production. Thank you for bringing it back. Thank you for Europe, it's much more convenient for me and my travels. Goodnight London. Goodnight London. Buona sera. Buona sera Oscar.
真是部好戏。谢谢你把它带回来。谢谢你，欧洲，这对我和我的旅行来说方便多了。晚安，伦敦。晚安，伦敦。晚上好。晚上好，奥斯卡。
No, by the way, I'm looking at my window at Westminster Abbey. Can you believe that? Isn't that wild? Got yourself a nice place there, huh? Am I going to wait, oh yeah, can you show me my room? Listen, I'm about to live with Sean. You're going to go stay with those guys, huh? Yeah, remember how you used to do that when you would travel with Sean
不，顺便说一下，我正从窗户看着威斯敏斯特教堂。你能相信吗？这不是很疯狂吗？你给自己找了个好地方，对吧？我要等一下，哦对了，你能带我看看我的房间吗？听着，我马上要和肖恩住在一起了。你要去和那些家伙住，对吧？是啊，还记得你以前和肖恩一起旅行时是怎么做的吗？
and go to all these wonderful places around the planet? Well, I get to do one now. You know what's so funny, when I heard that, I actually thought about your sort of crappy little voice being sad about that and then how you were gonna be excited that you were going to stay with Sean. Yeah, I love it. It's no Istanbul, but it'll do.
去往地球上所有这些美妙的地方？好吧，我现在也能做一次了。你知道最有趣的是什么吗？当我听到这个消息时，我其实想到了你那种糟糕的小嗓音，因为这件事而感到难过，然后想到你又要因为能和肖恩住在一起而感到兴奋。是啊，我喜欢。虽然比不上伊斯坦布尔，但也凑合了。
No, it's better. Or Venice, or Venice. Or Venice, that's a tight second. Both of them. But, Sean, it's going well so far? You remembering to look right when you step off the curb? Isn't that wild? I really am trying to get, and by the way,
不，这更好。或者威尼斯，或者威尼斯。或者威尼斯，那是紧随其后的第二名。两者都是。但是，肖恩，目前进展顺利吗？你记得走下路缘时要往右看吗？这不是很疯狂吗？我真的在努力尝试，顺便说一下，
you know the other thing? When you're walking on a sidewalk, I have to go to the left. No, you don't. What are you talking about? You're going to pass somebody. No. Yeah, because they're hoping you do that.
你知道另一件事吗？当你在人行道上走的时候，我得靠左走。不，你不用。你在说什么？你要超过某人。不。是啊，因为他们希望你那样做。
Are they? I'm telling you. No. Yeah, I'm telling you because I lean to the right and they're like, and then they lean to the right and then I lean to the right. They keep going to the right. You've been leaning right for years though.
他们希望吗？我告诉你。不。是啊，我告诉你是因为我向右倾斜，他们也向右倾斜，然后我又向右倾斜。他们一直往右走。不过你多年来一直都倾向于右边。
I think you and Will are going to jump parties on me soon. Wait, but you know that like you walk around London and you're like, wow, I get why JK Rowling wrote Harry Potter. Like it's so magical. Like it's incredible here. No, I do love that place. It's incredible. And people that live here that I talked to,
我觉得你和威尔很快就要背着我跳槽了。等等，但你知道吗，就像你在伦敦走来走去，你会觉得，哇，我明白JK·罗琳为什么写《哈利·波特》了。因为它太神奇了。这里真是不可思议。不，我确实喜欢那个地方。这太不可思议了。而且我交谈过的住在这里的人，
they're like, yeah, you know. Just kidding Rowling? What's that? Just kidding Rowling? Is that what it is? Just kidding Rowling, JK. Will, you've been to England, right? Do you like Europe? Do you've been to England, right?
他们会说，是啊，你知道的。开玩笑的罗琳？那是什么？开玩笑的罗琳？是这样吗？开玩笑的罗琳，JK。威尔，你去过英国，对吧？你喜欢欧洲吗？你去过英国，对吧？
Do you like Europe? Do you like England, London in particular? And here he comes. Don't try to bait me. Don't try to, it was a classic bait, man. Don't try to do it. I'm not gonna do it. Willie, why don't you come out?
你喜欢欧洲吗？你喜欢英国，特别是伦敦吗？他来了。别想诱导我。别想，这可是经典的诱饵，伙计。别想这么做。我不会上当的。威利，你为什么不出来？
Why don't you come out? Why don't you just move there? I don't know why you got yourself. I am gonna come out. Sean, I made a plan this morning. We're gonna come see your play in August. I'm not going to, we're going to go over the dates. I'm coming, Bradley and I are coming in Chappie.
你为什么不出来？你为什么不干脆搬到那里去？我不知道你为什么要这样。我会出来的。肖恩，我今天早上做了一个计划。我们八月份要去看你的戏。我不会，我们要核对一下日期。我会去的，布拉德利和我会在查皮（Chappie）那里。
No way, that's so nice. By the way, you can- You guys doing some reshoots? We're doing reshoots, yeah. We have tons of room, Willie. You can stay with us if you want. Fantastic. Yeah, it's unbelievably beautiful.
不会吧，那太好了。顺便说一下，你们可以——你们在补拍镜头吗？我们在补拍，是的。我们有足够的空间，威利。如果你愿意，你可以和我们住在一起。太棒了。是啊，这里美得令人难以置信。
Well, that I'm very excited for, but I hear you got there and it was in kind of shabby shape. You had to bring in a deep clean company? Yeah, when we got to this place that we got. No, no, no, no, not deep clean, but it has an elevator because it's an old townhouse. Oh, boy. And of course the elevator broke down. No, while you were in it again?
好吧，对此我非常兴奋，但我听说你到那儿的时候，它状况有点糟糕。你不得不请了一家深度清洁公司？是啊，当我们到达我们住的这个地方时。不，不，不，不，不是深度清洁，但它有一个电梯，因为它是一栋老联排别墅。哦，天哪。当然，电梯坏了。不，你又在里面的时候坏的？
Oh, man. No, I wasn't in it this time, But I keep a bottle of Valium in it. You know what, can I just say something? It might be user error at this point. Can I just say something? It might be what? User error, I think it's your fault or Scottie's fault. Yeah, sure.
哦，伙计。不，这次我不在里面，但我随身带着一瓶安定。你知道吗，我能说点什么吗？这可能已经是用户操作失误了。我能说点什么吗？可能是什么是？用户操作失误，我觉得是你的错或者斯科特的错。是啊，当然。
This is important to say at this juncture, which is because just in the times we live in, and I think that for you to be able to speak so openly and so bravely and so relatably about the shabby shape of the elevator in your townhouse in London. Yeah, this is the second dwelling you've been in with an elevator.
在当前这个关头说这一点很重要，因为在我们生活的时代，我认为你能如此公开、勇敢且感同身受地谈论你在伦敦联排别墅里那部电梯的糟糕状况。是啊，这是你住过的第二个有电梯的住所。
I've never been in a place with an elevator. Oh, but yeah, I'm renting it, I don't own it. But it's really beautiful. But it's, you know, so I keep a bottle of Valium in the corner in case it goes, but I did my exposure therapy. You don't need a full bottle, why don't you just keep one in your pocket?
我从来没住过有电梯的地方。哦，但确实，我是租的，不是我自己的。但它真的很漂亮。但是，你知道，所以我会在角落里放一瓶安定以防万一，但我做了暴露疗法。你不需要一整瓶，为什么不随身带一片呢？
Well, no, no. A bottle of Valium in the elevator? In the elevator, in case it shuts down and I have to wait for the repair guy and I don't need a full bottle, why don't you just keep one in your pocket? Well, no, no. A bottle of Valium in the elevator? In the elevator, in case it shuts down and I have to wait for the repair guy and I don't go crazy, so I'm just, I need, you know. Why don't you just put a gun in there? Put a gun in there and then just put it deep into your fucking mouth.
好吧，不，不。在电梯里放一瓶安定？在电梯里，以防它停运，我不得不等维修人员，我不需要一整瓶，为什么不随身带一片呢？好吧，不，不。在电梯里放一瓶安定？在电梯里，以防它停运，我不得不等维修人员，我不想发疯，所以我只是，我需要，你知道。你为什么不直接在里面放把枪？放把枪在里面，然后直接把它塞进你该死的嘴里。
Wait a second, first of all, your fucking therapist needs to be arrested. Because this is, that's absurd. No, I'm telling you because if something goes wrong and you're stuck in there for an hour while the guy gets there, I don't want to go crazy. I just want to like chill out. Well, that ship has passed.
等一下，首先，你的那个该死的治疗师需要被逮捕。因为这太荒谬了。不，我告诉你是因为如果出了什么问题，你被困在里面一个小时等那个人过来，我不想发疯。我只是想冷静一下。好吧，那艘船已经开走了。
Well, why don't you look within, man? I did, so I did exposure therapy and it's kind of working. What, you just get on the tube and just flash your jacket open? Yeah, it's really working. What does that mean, exposure therapy? So it's really fascinating. You sit there with your palms up and your eyes closed,
好吧，你为什么不向内看呢，伙计？我看了，所以我做了暴露疗法，而且有点效果。什么，你只是坐地铁然后把夹克敞开？是啊，真的很有用。暴露疗法是什么意思？这真的很迷人。你坐在那里，手心向上，闭上眼睛，
you have to repeat over and over a million times, you have to go, I'm walking down the hall, I see a small elevator and I step inside. I'm walking down the hall, I see a small elevator, I step inside. And you say that over and over and over again, for like 20 minutes, and your therapist will check in every two minutes
你必须一遍又一遍地重复一百万次，你必须说，我正走在走廊里，我看到一个小电梯，我走了进去。我正走在走廊里，我看到一个小电梯，我走了进去。你一遍又一遍地重复，持续大约20分钟，你的治疗师每两分钟会检查一次，
and say, where's your anxiety level? And it goes from 10 to eight to seven, to three to two to one, until you become bored with it. Then you move on to, I'm walking down the hall, I step into an elevator, and then the doors close. I'm walking down the hall,
然后问，你的焦虑水平是多少？它会从10降到8、7、3、2、1，直到你对它感到厌烦。然后你继续说，我正走在走廊里，我走进电梯，然后门关上了。我正走在走廊里，
I step into the elevator, and the doors close. And you just try to feel what that feels like over and over again, and it fucking works. And what are they charging you an hour for this? I don't remember. Because I used to do this in elementary school, when I would screw up, they'd make me write stuff on a chalkboard over and over and over again.
我走进电梯，门关上了。你只是试着一遍又一遍地感受那种感觉，它他妈的真的有用。他们每小时收你多少钱做这个？我不记得了。因为我上小学的时候经常这样做，当我搞砸的时候，他们会让我一遍又一遍地在黑板上写东西。
Like Homer Simpson. Yeah, it's called sentences, or whatever. Hey, you know what else works, Sean, is nutting up. Yeah, it's just called developing the backbone and the thicker skin and just getting older. You know? No, I know. You've been through a lot in your life
就像荷马·辛普森那样。是啊，这叫抄写句子，或者别的什么。嘿，你知道还有什么管用吗，肖恩，就是硬气起来。是啊，这叫培养脊梁骨和更厚的脸皮，然后慢慢变老。你知道吗？不，我知道。你一生中经历了很多，
and you are tough. I mean it, like you know how to deal with a lot of stuff and you get your head on your shoulders. Yeah, but it's claustrophobia. I mean, if you got stuck in that elevator that I had stuck in, you would've gone fucking bananas. Will, what's your plan today? Will, what Well was your planet out there in the Hamptons? My plan is pretty it's a little overcast and rainy. I was already I was up super early
你很坚强。我是说真的，你知道如何处理很多事情，而且你很有主见。是啊，但这是幽闭恐惧症。我是说，如果你被困在我被困住的那部电梯里，你会疯掉的。威尔，你今天有什么计划？威尔，你在汉普顿的计划是什么？我的计划是，天气有点阴沉多雨。我起得特别早，
Going over stuff with with a friend BC and Going over stuff. Yeah The edit he's working on the, right? How's stuff looking? It's looking pretty good, so we're doing that this morning early, I was up like five because he's in Europe and then. Aren't you close to getting a cut that you like?
和朋友BC一起过一遍东西，过一遍东西。是啊，他在剪辑，对吧？东西看起来怎么样？看起来还不错，所以我们今天早上很早就做了，我五点就起来了，因为他在欧洲，然后。你离得到一个你喜欢的剪辑版本还远吗？
Yeah, I mean, it's a work in progress, he's working away on it. Has he shown you his director's cut yet? There is, no, there's no director's cut yet, no, no. Okay. But, and then, you know, do my usual Are you happy with your performance that you've seen? I am yeah, I mean, I don't know it's no I'm happy with watching his performance. It's pretty I mean, it's it's something like you're starting to see yourself and in its context with
是啊，我是说，这是一个正在进行的工作，他正在努力剪辑。他给你看他的导演剪辑版了吗？还没有，没有导演剪辑版，没有，没有。好吧。但是，然后，你知道，做我通常的……你对你看到的自己的表演满意吗？我是，是啊，我是说，我不知道，不，我对看他的表演很满意。这很……我是说，这就像你开始看到自己，并将其置于背景中，
The one scene stuck next to another scene next to another scene like that's like it's a scary thing Like how's it's starting to feel, good? I think that we have a movie, I'll say that. You've been doing it a lot longer than I have, JB. You know how it is, and so you never know until you know. So I'm just kinda leaving it out there in software. Are you allowing it to become something different than what you had imagined it was going to be?
一个场景接着一个场景，这真是一件可怕的事情。感觉开始好起来了吗？我想我们有一部电影了，我只能这么说。你做这一行比我久得多，JB。你知道是怎么回事，所以不到最后你永远不知道。所以我只是把它留在软件里。你允许它变成和你想象中不一样的东西吗？
Yeah. Because inevitably it is. As you know, it always changes. I'm excited for you to see it, for both what you had imagined it was going to be. Because inevitably it is. As you know, it always changes. I'm excited for you to see it, for both of you to see it. Sean's in it as well, and Sean's great. So he's still in it. You're saying he's still in it? Yeah, as of this morning.
是啊。因为不可避免地它会变。如你所知，它总是在变化。我很兴奋让你看到它，为了你想象中它会成为的样子。因为不可避免地它会变。如你所知，它总是在变化。我很兴奋让你看到它，让你们俩看到它。肖恩也在里面，而且肖恩很棒。所以他还在里面。你是说他还在里面？是啊，截至今天早上。
Okay. This morning. But I'm excited for you guys to get your thoughts. I can't wait. To hear your thoughts on it. I'm wide open. That'll be be forthcoming, but we'll see. What else are you excited about? Our guest today.
好的。今天早上。但我很兴奋能听到你们的想法。我等不及了。听到你们对它的想法。我完全开放。那会有的，但我们走着瞧。你还对什么感到兴奋？我们今天的嘉宾。
Well, I'm excited about our guest today. I know, I know. Sorry, Sean, we'll get there. I was about to, I was just answering the question. Sean, are you in a rush? Yeah, he's got a dinner. Are you, I'm sorry, are your knickers in a twist? Yeah, are you keeping the palace waiting?
好吧，我对我们今天的嘉宾感到兴奋。我知道，我知道。抱歉，肖恩，我们会谈到的。我正要，我只是在回答问题。肖恩，你很赶时间吗？是啊，他有个晚餐。你是，抱歉，你心烦意乱了吗？是啊，你在让王室成员久等吗？
By the way, we're so lucky, we're so lucky because now we do get, we get to get to our guest, which is gonna be just, he's a palate cleanser in every way. This guy is so, he's done everything. And he's one of those guys who classically trained, Juilliard trained, and then so he's done everything from Broadway to like Indies to like, you know, cool plays to the biggest of biggest of biggest of hits.
顺便说一下，我们太幸运了，我们太幸运了，因为现在我们确实可以请到我们的嘉宾了，他将是……他各方面都是一个清口剂。这家伙太……他什么都做过。他是那种受过古典训练、朱莉亚学院训练的人，所以他从百老汇到独立电影，再到酷炫的戏剧，再到最大最大的热门作品，他都做过。
He's like just a bona fide movie star. I've had the pleasure of getting to know him a little bit over the last couple of years because we've worked together on a project together, me and a producing role, but him as the star of, he's incredible. You guys know him from all his performances, the second I start to name it, Sean's gonna go,
他就像一个货真价实的电影明星。过去几年我有幸稍微了解了他一下，因为我们一起参与了一个项目，我担任制片人，而他是主演，他太不可思议了。你们从他所有的表演中认识他，我一提到名字，肖恩就会说，
I know who it is. He's been in a gazillion Marvel movies, and within the Marvelverse, he then graduated and became a sort of a different character altogether. You know him as Captain America. I know him as Anthony Thank you, I have so much to say about those first Like I wanted to see which one of y'all is gonna talk about who had the most Tesla's in their driveway Jason had the most Teslas in their driveway. That'd be Jason. That'd be Jason.
我知道是谁。他出演了无数部漫威电影，在漫威宇宙中，他随后毕业并成为了一个完全不同的角色。你们认识他是美国队长。我认识他是安东尼。谢谢，关于那些第一部……我有太多话要说了。我想看看你们谁会谈论谁的车道上特斯拉最多。杰森的车道上特斯拉最多。那肯定是杰森。那肯定是杰森。
I've never owned one. I'm trying to get it away from my wife, but she will not. Anthony, by the way, you should know that Jason's glass house is so fragile up. He's in his guest house overlooking his screen house, overlooking his main house right now. Okay?
我从来没拥有过。我正试图把它从我妻子那里弄走，但她不肯。安东尼，顺便说一下，你应该知道杰森的玻璃房非常脆弱。他现在正坐在俯瞰他屏幕房的客房里，俯瞰着他的主屋。好吧？
Anyway, Anthony Mackie, dude, thank you. Thank you for being here. Welcome to Smart List. It's so great to have you. Yeah, it's so nice to meet you. No, thanks for having me, man. I appreciate it. It's been a long time coming.
总之，安东尼·麦凯，伙计，谢谢你。谢谢你来到这里。欢迎来到“聪明清单”。很高兴有你。是啊，很高兴见到你。不，谢谢你们邀请我，伙计。我很感激。这一天等了很久了。
Yeah. It's been a long time coming. Where do we find you? Are you at home? No, I'm in Budapest right now. And I'll tell you what. Wow. A black man in Budapest for the summer is,
是啊。这一天等了很久了。我们在哪里找到你？你在家吗？不，我现在在布达佩斯。我告诉你。哇。一个黑人在布达佩斯过夏天，
I mean, god damn. It's like, I found my people. I don't know what, I don't know. It's like they shot me out of a rocket and landed me. Like I did something right in my life. You know what I mean? They're like, you get to go to Budapest for the summer. You know?
我是说，该死。就像是，我找到了我的人民。我不知道，我不知道。就像他们把我从火箭上射出来，然后让我着陆。就像我生活中做对了什么事一样。你知道我的意思吗？他们说，你夏天可以去布达佩斯。你知道吗？
What do you mean? What do you mean they just love you there? Well, everybody loves you everywhere. No, it's different here. Like everybody's nice, like the food is good, the city's beautiful and historic. You know, there's a dirty river, like just everything you want.
你是什么意思？你是什么意思他们只是在那里爱你？好吧，每个人在任何地方都爱你。不，这里不一样。每个人都很友善，食物很好，城市既美丽又有历史感。你知道，有一条脏河，就像你想要的一切。
You know, every day is sunny. The Budapestians are fucking great people. I love them. I love that. There's a lot of stuff that's shooting there lately, huh? Like, what are you doing there, can you say? I'm doing a show for Apple, so nobody will see it, called 12, 12, 12.
你知道，每一天都是晴天。布达佩斯人真是他妈的太棒了。我爱他们。我喜欢这一点。最近那里有很多东西在拍摄，对吧？比如，你在那里做什么，可以说吗？我正在为苹果公司做一个节目，所以没人会看到它，叫《12, 12, 12》。
12, 12, 12. Gotcha. Apple is huge, people will see it. Yeah, come on. Yeah, Apple is great, man. Yeah, it's like this F1 thing, that's making a lot of money. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, Apple's great, man. Formula One, like it's this F1 thing that's making a lot of money. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, Apple's great.
12, 12, 12。明白了。苹果公司很大，人们会看到的。是啊，得了吧。是啊，苹果很棒，伙计。是啊，就像这个F1的东西，赚了很多钱。是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊，苹果很棒，伙计。一级方程式，就像这个F1的东西，赚了很多钱。是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊，苹果很棒。
I'm excited. It's my first time, well, my second time on Apple because I did the first movie on Apple, actually, The Banker, and this is my first time back. So they've been great, man. It's been wonderful. They gave me the opportunity to come to Budapest for the first time. Amazing.
我很兴奋。这是我第一次，好吧，我在苹果公司的第二次，因为我实际上在苹果公司拍了第一部电影，《银行家》，这是我第一次回来。所以他们很棒，伙计。这太美妙了。他们给了我第一次去布达佩斯的机会。太棒了。
So how, is it a bunch of episodes? So you're there for a while. It's eight episodes. It's me and Jamie Dornan. So they're, this is our second time working together. I'm like, you know, it's, we're and Kari who directed Falcon Winter Soldier is directing it. Oh cool.
那么，是一堆剧集吗？所以你要在那里待一段时间。是八集。是我和杰米·多南。所以他们，这是我们第二次合作。我像，你知道，我们是……而且执导《猎鹰与冬兵》的卡里正在执导它。哦，酷。
So it's a pretty good, it's a pretty, pretty good group. Great scripts, like great stories, you know, it's a good time. And it's in Budapest. It sounds like it's big, it sounds like there's a lot of action. It's huge, you know who you're talking to? Yeah, yeah. Okay, you're not the only one, I mean it's huge, buddy.
所以这是一个相当不错的，相当不错的团队。剧本很棒，故事很棒，你知道，这是一个好时光。而且是在布达佩斯。听起来很大，听起来有很多动作戏。很大，你知道你在和谁说话吗？是啊，是啊。好的，你不是唯一一个，我是说这很大，伙计。
We're doing well here, you know? It's okay. It's action and it's stunts and it's a muscular project, yes? It's a lot of testosterone. Some might call it toxic, but I don't give a fuck. A ballsy ring. Ballsy.
我们在这里做得很好，你知道吗？没关系。这是动作戏，是特技，是一个肌肉发达的项目，对吧？有很多睾丸激素。有些人可能会称之为有毒，但我他妈的不在乎。一个有胆量的戒指。有胆量。
So how long you there? If you're doing eight episodes, you're there for five months? Five months between here and London. And it is like, when I come to London in two weeks, I'm coming to see your show too. Yes. Yeah, I'll be there, I'll be there.
那你要在那里待多久？如果你要做八集，你要待五个月？在我和伦敦之间待五个月。而且就像，当我两周后去伦敦时，我也会去看你的演出。是的。是啊，我会去的，我会去的。
Should I wear like my Liza Minnelli shit? Like Moe and Beyonce shit? Yeah, for sure. Okay. I know we're not going to be. Tommy Jones stuff works too. We're not going to be open in two weeks, you come back in July.
我应该穿得像丽莎·明内利那样吗？像莫和碧昂丝那样？是啊，当然。好的。我知道我们不会。汤米·琼斯的东西也行。我们两周后不会开演，你七月份再回来。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, two weeks is in July. Oh, well, end of July, July 31st. Oh shit, you've been. August. So you go back and forth, you guys shoot stuff in England, you shoot stuff in Hungary, back and forth. No, I'm shooting Avengers in England and I'm shooting this in Hungary. Okay, gotcha.
是啊，是啊，是啊，两周后就是七月了。哦，好吧，七月底，7月31日。哦，该死，你一直。八月。所以你们来回奔波，你们在英国拍东西，在匈牙利拍东西，来回奔波。不，我在英国拍《复仇者联盟》，我在匈牙利拍这个。好的，明白了。
Wait a second, so you're going back and forth to London, you're doing Avengers, Sean, hold your questions. No, I just. Sean is a massive, massive Avengers Marvel. And you're working with, you have the misfortune of working with Downey, Sean is a massive, massive, adventurous marvel. And you're working with, you have the misfortune of working with Downey, I'm sure, over there with Robert. I mean, what a trip.
等一下，所以你来回伦敦，你在拍《复仇者联盟》，肖恩，忍住你的问题。不，我只是。肖恩是一个巨大的、巨大的《复仇者联盟》漫威迷。而且你正在和……你有不幸和唐尼一起工作，肖恩是一个巨大的、巨大的《复仇者联盟》漫威迷。而且你正在和……你有不幸和唐尼一起工作，我确定，和罗伯特在那边。我是说，真是趟旅程。
Hey, he serves up a great lunch, man. I mean, everybody's healthy, you know, it's really good. We drink his bottled chill brew. It's a good time, it's a good time, it's a good, we drink his bottled, chilled brew. It's a good time, it's a good time, it's a good time. So Anthony, with all this time away from home, what's the main thing you find yourself missing? I ask, because it's on my mind, I just had my daughter call me from,
嘿，他提供了很棒的午餐，伙计。我是说，每个人都很健康，你知道，这真的很好。我们喝他瓶装的冷萃咖啡。这是一个好时光，这是一个好时光，这是一个好时光，我们喝他瓶装的冷萃咖啡。这是一个好时光，这是一个好时光，这是一个好时光。那么安东尼，在远离家乡的这段时间里，你发现自己最想念的是什么？我问是因为这在我脑海里，我刚接到我女儿从……
she's on a trip to actually also to Europe on some sort of camp thing, and she's feeling really homesick. But so, what are you missing most about home right now? Yeah. I hate to say this because it fits in y'all's conversation earlier, but I miss my cars, man.
她实际上也在欧洲参加某种夏令营之类的旅行，她感到非常想家。但所以，你现在最想念家里的什么？是啊。我不想说这个，因为它符合你们之前的谈话，但我怀念我的车，伙计。
Yeah, yeah. I miss driving when I'm away from home. I just want to, I'm a very, very like home-strucking dude. So literally I'll go, after going to the gym, I'll get a po'boy and a ice cold beer, sit in the garage and work on my cars all day. Wait, so after the gym, you find a real fatty, carbohydrate-ridden snack and some puffy-making beer.
是啊，是啊。我离开家时很怀念开车。我只是想，我是一个非常、非常恋家的人。所以实际上，去完健身房后，我会买一个波波三明治和一杯冰镇啤酒，坐在车库里整天摆弄我的车。等等，所以去完健身房后，你找了一个真正油腻、碳水化合物含量高的零食和一些让人发胖的啤酒。
Sorry, Jason's one of those guys who doesn't eat pizza, by the way. Exactly. But I came out with a big fat face. I gotta like spend every minute of every day trying to- But that's the whole point of going to the gym, man. You go to the gym and you're like, then you go get a po'boy.
抱歉，杰森是那种不吃披萨的人，顺便说一下。完全正确。但我出来时脸很大。我得花每一天每一分钟试图……但这就是去健身房的全部意义，伙计。你去健身房，然后你就像，然后你去买一个波波三明治。
Exactly. I exercise so that I can be a little bit bad. I don't exercise. Well, you look great, man. You look like you're- Anthony, I love you. You look like you have one of those pelotons. You know what? You look like you do Pilates is what it is. How dare you.
完全正确。我锻炼是为了我可以稍微坏一点。我不锻炼。好吧，你看上去很棒，伙计。你看上去就像你……安东尼，我爱你。你看上去就像你有那种Peloton健身车。你知道吗？你看上去就像你做普拉提，就是这样。你怎么敢。
So you miss driving, you miss your cars. Where's home, LA? You do have like a Pilates, not your body, but your temperament and like the way that you are in the world, you seem like a Pilates person. I tell you what, I am hearing that that's what I need to make a friend of, is Pilates. Yeah, it's good stretching.
所以你怀念开车，你怀念你的车。家在哪里，洛杉矶？你确实有一种普拉提，不是你的身体，而是你的气质，以及你在世界上的方式，你看起来像个做普拉提的人。我告诉你，我听说那是我需要结交的朋友，就是普拉提。是啊，这拉伸很好。
It is good. So it's got all the stretching of yoga, but it's got some core strengthening, muscle building stuff. Anyway. I heard it gives you outstanding sexual stamina. Wait, what? He doesn't need that.
确实很好。所以它有瑜伽所有的拉伸，但它有一些核心强化、肌肉锻炼的东西。总之。我听说它能给你带来出色的性耐力。等等，什么？他不需要那个。
That's what I heard, dude. I heard a friend of mine started doing Pilates. I could use a little bump in that as well. Thank you. I like it. Just maybe another 20, 30 seconds would be a friend of mine started doing a little bump in that as well. Thank you Just maybe another 20 30 seconds would be Wait Anthony's Speaking of relationships. I love this. I love this I'm just waiting for you to get your first fucking question. I'm
我就是这么听说的，伙计。我听说我一个朋友开始做普拉提了。我也能用那个稍微提升一下。谢谢。我喜欢它。也许再过20、30秒，我一个朋友开始做那个，我也能用那个稍微提升一下。谢谢，也许再过20、30秒，等等，安东尼在谈论关系。我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个，我只是在等你的第一个该死的问题。我……
My clothes are off. Go ahead. Wait. I love it. I love it, JB. I'm telling you I love it. I'm having fun. It's fun. Do you notice that, Sean? He brings on a guest. He just sits back. He basically introduces them and then he's like, okay. Not at all. We're having a conversation. We're having a conversation. And you were asking... We covered a lot of shit. This is going really well.
我的衣服脱了。继续。等等。我喜欢它。我喜欢它，JB。我告诉你我喜欢它。我玩得很开心。这很有趣。你注意到了吗，肖恩？他请来一位嘉宾。他只是坐着。他基本上介绍了他们，然后他就说，好的。一点也不。我们在对话。我们在对话。而且你问的是……我们涵盖了很多东西。这进行得非常顺利。
Yeah, this is going really well. Yeah, this is going very well. How dare you? Oh, sorry, okay. Move on to the taint exercise. Anthony, just to make J.B. feel better. Anthony, how'd you get your start in show business? Ha ha ha!
是啊，这进行得非常顺利。是啊，这进行得非常顺利。你怎么敢？哦，抱歉，好的。继续做那个尾骨练习。安东尼，只是为了让J.B.感觉好一点。安东尼，你是怎么进入演艺圈的？哈哈哈哈！
Which I really do want to know. By the way, J.B., you will be jealous. Let's talk a little bit for a second. And Anthony, I've asked you about this in person too, like, you went to Juilliard, which is so rad. It's like the gold standard. I mean, that must have been, talk a little bit about like, getting into Juilliard,
我真的很想知道。顺便说一下，J.B.，你会嫉妒的。让我们谈一会儿。安东尼，我也曾亲自问过你这个问题，比如，你去了朱莉亚学院，这太酷了。这就像黄金标准。我是说，那一定……谈谈进入朱莉亚学院，
and was it like a dream come true, or were you like, yeah, big good job? Did you have a cross pass with Laura Linney there? I think she's a big wig over there. I never saw Laura Linney. She was never there when I was there. Patti LuPone was there all the time, which was amazing. But it all started in New Orleans.
这是一个梦想成真，还是你觉得，是啊，做得好？你在那里和劳拉·琳妮有过交集吗？我觉得她是那里的重量级人物。我从没见过劳拉·琳妮。我在那里的时候她从不在。帕蒂·卢波恩一直都在，这太棒了。但这一切都始于新奥尔良。
I mean, I went to this school called New Orleans Center for Creative Arts, which is pretty much like fame, but in New Orleans. And I just loved it. Like, it was amazing. It taught me everything and I got to, New Orleans is a very segregated city, so getting to meet and see people
我是说，我去了这所叫新奥尔良创意艺术中心的学校，这几乎就像《名扬四海》，但在新奥尔良。我只是喜欢它。就像，这太棒了。它教会了我一切，而且我能够……新奥尔良是一个非常种族隔离的城市，所以能够见到并看到来自城市另一边的人，
from the other side of the city was mind blowing how different it was on the other side of the track. So it forced me to want to get out of New York, I mean New Orleans. So I went to boarding school in North Carolina at North Carolina School of the Arts. And I consider that to be my year of time. Like everybody's been arrested,
这真是令人大开眼界，铁轨另一边是多么不同。所以它迫使我想要离开纽约，我是说新奥尔良。所以我去了北卡罗来纳州的北卡罗来纳艺术学院读寄宿学校。我把那一年视为我的时间。就像每个人都被逮捕过，
my year of jail time was in Winston Salem, North Carolina. Oh really, why, why? Why, it was bad. Have you ever been to Winston Salem? No, no. It was really bad. Winston Salem in 1996 was some shit, you hear me? Oh really, really.
我的监狱时间是在北卡罗来纳州的温斯顿-塞勒姆。哦，真的吗，为什么，为什么？为什么，那很糟糕。你去过温斯顿-塞勒姆吗？不，不。那真的很糟糕。1996年的温斯顿-塞勒姆真是烂透了，你听到了吗？哦，真的，真的。
So I made it out, I did my bid, I got out, you know what I mean? And the man couldn't hold me down forever. So I moved up to New York and auditioned and got into Juilliard from North Carolina. And moved to New York when I was 18. And it was crazy. Wait, so Anthony, so you grow up in New Orleans. You were born and raised there? Yeah, born and raised was crazy. Wait, so Anthony, so you start, so you grow up in New Orleans, you were born and raised there?
所以我成功逃出来了，我服完了我的刑期，我出来了，你知道我的意思吗？那个人不能永远压制我。所以我搬到了纽约，试镜并从北卡罗来纳州进入了朱莉亚学院。18岁时搬到了纽约。这太疯狂了。等等，所以安东尼，所以你在新奥尔良长大。你是土生土长的吗？是啊，土生土长的，太疯狂了。等等，所以安东尼，所以你开始，所以你在新奥尔良长大，你是土生土长的吗？
Yeah, born and raised, yeah. Seven-Wall Boscoville hardhead. So then your first real exposure to, as you say, the other side of the tracks was going to this really cool art school where you got to see some folks that are from a different socioeconomic background and they're coming to see some of the productions and stuff like that.
是啊，土生土长的，是啊。七墙博斯科维尔硬头。所以你第一次真正接触到，正如你所说，铁轨的另一边是去这所非常酷的艺术学校，在那里你看到了来自不同社会经济背景的人，他们来看一些作品之类的东西。
The seed gets planted to be an artist, an actor, yeah? And you say, okay, I'm not bad at this, you're getting some nice accolades? Such that you think you can take on more? Not at all. It was just, it was something, I was probably the worst actor at my school, but. Really?
种子被种下成为一名艺术家、演员，对吧？你说，好的，我不擅长这个，你得到了一些不错的赞誉？以至于你认为你可以承担更多？一点也不。这只是，这只是某件事，我可能是学校里最差的演员，但是。真的吗？
It kept my interest, you know? Like, you know, the idea of being in a room with different types of people and doing different types of shit, it was almost like every day was summer camp. Like, I looked forward to going there every day, because you would go there half a day and then regular school half a day.
它保持了我的兴趣，你知道吗？就像，你知道，和不同类型的人在一个房间里做不同类型的事情的想法，几乎就像每天都是夏令营。就像，我每天都期待去那里，因为你每天去那里半天，然后常规学校半天。
And it was just like a bunch of people in a room that I identified with, people that I got along with. And it was a school that was half dancers, so we had all these smokin' chicks in a dance program. So I was like, fuck. I just showed my, I have a 16-year-old son, I showed him my year I have a 16 year old son, I showed him my yearbook from high school and he was like, yo, those are the girls. And I'm like, this
而且那就像一群我认同的人，我相处得来的人。而且那所学校有一半是舞者，所以我们在舞蹈项目中有很多火辣的女孩。所以我当时想，去他的。我刚展示了我的……我有一个16岁的儿子，我给他看了我的高中年鉴，他说，哟，那是那些女孩。我说，这
is what girls looked like when I was in school. Fuck you. Like you got it good. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Was it a common thing for the folks where you grew up to like go into the arts, become an actor, go to this art school? Not become an actor. I mean, in New Orleans, you know, every little boy grows up wanting to be a trumpet player. You know, everybody wants to be a musician. Everybody wants to march in a parade.
就是我上学时女孩的样子。去你的。就像你过得很好。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。在你长大的地方，人们去从事艺术、成为演员、去这所艺术学校是一种普遍现象吗？不是成为演员。我是说，在新奥尔良，你知道，每个小男孩长大都想成为小号手。你知道，每个人都想成为音乐家。每个人都想在游行中行进。
Right. But were your parents musicians or in the arts at all? No, hell no. My daddy worked. My daddy was a roofer. So it was six of us. He had to work. So my mom was a-
对。但你的父母是音乐家或从事艺术吗？不，见鬼不。我爸爸工作。我爸爸是个屋顶工。所以我们有六个。他必须工作。所以我妈妈是……
Oh, fuck, roofing in New Orleans too. That is not- Yeah, my mom was a homemaker and my dad was a roofer. So it, but they always pressed on us education and going to school. So it was very important to them that we did something that fulfilled our dreams and kept us interested. But also probably they had their eye on practicality too.
哦，去他的，在新奥尔良做屋顶工。那不是……是啊，我妈妈是家庭主妇，我爸爸是屋顶工。所以，但他们总是向我们强调教育和上学。所以对他们来说，我们做一些实现梦想并保持兴趣的事情非常重要。但也可能他们也着眼于实用性。
It sounds like they were not afraid of good hard work and some pleasant predictability about income and providing, were they sort of, you sure you want to pursue acting or the arts is something that like, how about getting like a quote unquote real job? Was there pressure for you to do that as well? No, not at all.
听起来他们不怕艰苦的工作和一些关于收入和供养的令人愉快的可预测性，他们是否有点，你确定你想追求表演或艺术，比如，找一份所谓的“真正的工作”怎么样？你也有压力要那样做吗？不，一点也不。
My parents, my dad had one rule, do whatever you want, be the best at it, just don't go to jail. Oh, that's cool. That was it. Like you can be a damn garbage man, just be the best garbage man and don't go to jail. That's it.
我父母有一个原则，做任何你想做的事，做到最好，只是别进监狱。哦，那太酷了。就是这样。就像你可以成为一个该死的垃圾工，只要成为最好的垃圾工，别进监狱。就是这样。
Like growing up in New Orleans in the 80s and 90s, it was such a rough city. It was, I mean, it was the murder capital of the world. I mean, there were, in a city of 700,000 people, four to 500 people were getting murdered a year. So, first square capital, we were literally the murder capital of the world. Wow, I didn't know that.
就像在80年代和90年代的新奥尔良长大，那是一个非常粗糙的城市。那，我是说，那是世界谋杀之都。我是说，在70万人口的城市里，一年有四到五百人被谋杀。所以，第一广场之都，我们简直是世界谋杀之都。哇，我不知道。
So, yeah, it was wildly dangerous in the early 90s. Did you have brothers and sisters, or were you an only child? Five of them, yeah. Wow. We're all vastly different and very different. Anybody else go into the arts? No, no, no, no, no, yeah. Yeah. Wow. Yeah. And we're all vastly different and very different. Anybody else go into the arts? No, no, no, no, no, no.
所以，是啊，90年代初非常危险。你有兄弟姐妹吗，还是你是独生子？五个，是啊。哇。我们都非常不同，非常不同。还有其他人从事艺术吗？不，不，不，不，不，是啊。是啊。哇。是啊。而且我们都非常不同，非常不同。还有其他人从事艺术吗？不，不，不，不，不，不。
My brother was a singer, but he also played tennis, so all that shit's weird, you know what I mean? So, I mean, that's amazing. So you go and then you go to North Carolina, then you go up, you get into Juilliard, you go to Juilliard, and I was under this. So you graduate Juilliard, you've got a degree from arguably like the premier place to get an acting degree,
我哥哥是个歌手，但他也会打网球，所以所有这些都很奇怪，你知道我的意思吗？所以，我是说，这太神奇了。所以你去，然后你去北卡罗来纳，然后你上去，你进入朱莉亚学院，你去朱莉亚学院，我当时在……所以你从朱莉亚学院毕业，你拥有一个可以说是获得表演学位的首选地方的学位，
certainly in the States, and is it like, okay, the day after you graduate, is it like everybody's knocking at your door, or is it just to hit the streets and start auditioning like everybody else? Well, you do this thing called league scenes and you invite all the agents and all the agencies to come see the graduating class do their monologues. Like a showcase.
当然是在美国，是这样吗，毕业后的第二天，就像每个人都在敲你的门，还是就像其他人一样走上街头开始试镜？好吧，你做一件叫“联盟场景”的事情，你邀请所有的经纪人和所有的代理机构来看毕业班表演他们的独白。就像一个展示。
A showcase, yeah. And everybody comes and from that, hopefully you'll get an agent or a manager. And I got lucky. I did these three scenes and they were fine, it was cool. But what really helped me was when I was in school, we wrote this play about Tupac called Up Against the Wind.
一个展示，是啊。每个人都来了，从那以后，希望你能得到一个经纪人或经理。我很幸运。我做了这三个场景，它们很好，很酷。但真正帮助我的是我在学校时，我们写了一部关于图帕克的戏，叫《逆风而行》。
Yes. And we all did it. Like, there was a girl, Rosemary in a directing program, Michael in a writing program and all of us actors. We all wrote and produced the scene ourselves, I mean, the show ourselves at school. So when we did the show, Jim Nicola from New York Theater Workshop came to see the show
是的。我们都做了。就像，有一个女孩，罗斯玛丽在导演项目，迈克尔在写作项目，我们所有的演员。我们都在学校自己写并制作了这个场景，我是说，我们自己制作了这部戏。所以当我们做这部戏时，纽约剧院工作室的吉姆·尼古拉来看了这部戏，
and was like, I want to move this off Broadway. So it was a big problem at Juilliard because you're not allowed to do outside work while you're a student. And it came down. But it was a gray area because you guys had started it at the school. We started it at the school. Right.
并说，我想把它搬到外百老汇。所以这在朱莉亚学院是个大问题，因为你作为学生不允许做校外工作。它降下来了。但这是一个灰色地带，因为你们是在学校开始的。我们在学校开始的。对。
And it was very eye opening because there was a fight between me and the staff if I would do this play off Broadway which was created at the school or if I would do the checkoff play, which was created at the school, or if I would do the checkoff play for my final grade of the year. Right. So we were going back and forth about that, and they were very adamant
而且这非常令人大开眼界，因为我和员工之间有一场争论，如果我做这部在外百老汇的戏，它是学校创作的，或者如果我做契诃夫的戏，它是学校创作的，或者如果我做契诃夫的戏作为我那一年的最终成绩。对。所以我们为此来回争论，他们非常坚持，
about not letting me do this play. And then the play caught fire and took off, and all of a sudden, everybody was a supporter. Like there was a teacher who was interviewed by the New York Times, and true story, this is still in print, she said, usually the black kids just sit around and wait to see who's going to play our fellow,
不让我做这部戏。然后这部戏火了，起飞了，突然之间，每个人都成了支持者。就像有一位老师接受《纽约时报》采访，真实故事，这还在印刷中，她说，通常黑人孩子只是坐着等看谁来演我们的同伴，
but it's great that they created something that they can go and do in the New York theater. Whoa! What? What does that even mean? It means she was a fucking idiot? Yeah, what it means she was a fucking idiot That must have lit a fire on your like a little bit to be like like I'm gonna yeah like yeah
但他们创造了一些他们可以去纽约剧院表演的东西，这太棒了。哇！什么？那甚至是什么意思？这意味着她是个他妈的白痴？是啊，这意味着她是个他妈的白痴。那一定点燃了你内心的火，让你觉得……我会……是啊，就像……
And that was my biggest thing like coming out of that school It was it was really eye-opening for many different reasons, because I went to go see a play like every two weeks, and I saw so much bad theater, but I saw so much good theater. Yeah. You know, and so much small theater, and innovative and courageous theater.
那是我的大事，从那所学校出来，因为很多不同的原因，这真的令人大开眼界，因为我每两周去看一次戏，我看到了很多糟糕的戏剧，但我看到了很多好的戏剧。是啊。你知道，还有很多小剧场，创新和勇敢的戏剧。
And it really just formed and shaped me. What I saw really formed and shaped me more than what I learned in school. Yeah. And now, you find yourself, sorry Sean, you find yourself at a place of great success with tons of momentum and futures wide open. Did you allow yourself to see yourself at this place,
它真的塑造了我。我所看到的比我在学校学到的更塑造了我。是啊。现在，你发现自己，抱歉肖恩，你发现自己处于一个巨大的成功和巨大的动力之中，未来完全开放。你允许自己看到自己处于这个位置吗，
at this age, or are you kind of like, you know, it's a tough question to answer, but are you where you thought you would be? Are you over performing, under performing? You've got to be happy. You've got to be content. You know, this is a weird business. And you know, psychologically it's a huge mind fuck
在这个年龄，还是你有点像，你知道，这是一个很难回答的问题，但你是在你认为你会成为的地方吗？你是在超常发挥，还是表现不佳？你一定很高兴。你一定很满足。你知道，这是一个奇怪的行业。而且你知道，从心理上讲，这是一个巨大的精神折磨，
to be a part of this business. Because I never thought I would be here. Like I never, when I got into this business, I didn't say, oh, I want to be famous, or I want to be a movie star. I literally dreamed about being a working actor. Like I wanted to work at the Guthrie, I wanted to work at Penumbra.
成为这个行业的一部分。因为我从没想过我会在这里。就像我从没，当我进入这个行业时，我没说，哦，我想出名，或者我想成为电影明星。我真的梦想成为一名职业演员。就像我想在格思里工作，我想在彭布拉工作。
I wanted to work- That's why you've had longevity. And that was the focus of my career. Like, how can I do these great roles, you know, these great American theater roles in great theaters around the country, you know? And it just so happened, you know, because it sounds like such an asshole story.
我想工作……这就是你拥有长寿的原因。那是我的职业重点。就像，我怎么能扮演这些伟大的角色，你知道，这些伟大的美国戏剧角色，在全国伟大的剧院里，你知道吗？而且碰巧，你知道，因为它听起来像个混蛋故事。
So, when we were doing up against the Wind, there was this amazing casting director named Molly Finn, Guy Russell. And she was in New York, she came to see the play, and Curtis Hansen was putting together 8 Mile. Right. That's right. So she came to see the play, I get to audition for Curtis Hanson, and I was always a huge fan of Curtis from LA Confidential, from all the shit he had did. And my audition, like it was just funny,
所以，当我们做《逆风而行》时，有一位了不起的选角导演叫莫莉·芬恩，盖伊·拉塞尔。她在纽约，她来看了这部戏，柯蒂斯·汉森正在筹备《8英里》。对。没错。所以她来看了这部戏，我有机会为柯蒂斯·汉森试镜，我一直是柯蒂斯从《洛城机密》开始的忠实粉丝，从他做过的所有事情开始。我的试镜，就像这很有趣，
I always had a belief, if you get people to direct in you and working with you, that's because they're interested in you. If you audition and they go, good job kid, thanks for coming in, then nine times out of 10, you ain't getting that job. So I walk in and I meet Curtis, sit down, Curtis was a cool cat, like love him to death,
我一直有一个信念，如果你让人指导你并与你合作，那是因为他们对你感兴趣。如果你试镜，他们说，干得好孩子，谢谢你来，那么十有八九，你得不到那份工作。所以我走进去见到柯蒂斯，坐下来，柯蒂斯是个酷猫，就像爱死他了，
and I asked him, I said, so that was right when, like a year after Wonder Boys had came out, and I said, Curtis, I have a question for you before we start. He's like, yeah, sure, go ahead. So I was like, Wonder Boys. I'm like, was that meant to be an ode to Alfred Hitchcock or were you directing it in a sense towards the ideals and teachings of Hitchcock in the way he worked?
我问他，我说，那正好是《天才小子》上映一年后，我说，柯蒂斯，在开始之前我有个问题想问你。他说，好啊，没问题，你问吧。我说，关于《天才小子》。我想问，那是为了向阿尔弗雷德·希区柯克致敬吗？还是说你在某种意义上是按照希区柯克的理念和教学方式来执导这部电影的？
So he goes, whoa, what are you talking about? What do you mean? So I explained to him what I saw in the movie and what he did with Tobey Maguire and the backdrops in the scene and the escalating visual aspect that tied into the mental frustration of the character. And we talked for like an hour about Wonder Boys.
他说，哇，你在说什么？什么意思？于是我向他解释了我在电影中看到的，以及他如何处理托比·马奎尔、场景中的背景，还有那种与角色内心挫败感相呼应的视觉升级。我们聊了一个小时关于《天才小子》的话题。
I never read, never did my audition. So I come out and I'm like, fuck. Oops. I blew my time. I blew my time. So I'm like, don't like fuck. Oops. I blew my tie. So I'm like don't do that again. Don't do that again. So three weeks later he called and he was like yo cast somebody else in a role that you came in for but there's another role. It's only four days. If you, I don't want to
我没读剧本，也没去试镜。所以我出来的时候就想，该死。糟了。我搞砸了。我搞砸了。所以我对自己说，别再这样了。别再这样了。三周后他打电话给我，他说，嘿，你来试镜的那个角色已经定别人了，但还有另一个角色。只有四天戏份。如果你，我不想冒犯你。我知道你是科班出身的演员，但如果你愿意的话，我很希望能让你来底特律。我说，当然愿意，柯蒂斯·汉森。于是我飞到底特律，和柯蒂斯·汉森坐在一起吃晚饭，聊了大概两周。这本来只有四天戏份。对，没错，他说，你之后还有别的安排吗？对吧？他说，你之后还有别的安排吗？我说，没有。
offend you. I know you're a trained actor, but if you're willing to do it You know, I'd love to have you in Detroit. So I'm like hell. Yes, Curtis Hanson. Yeah, so fly to Detroit and Just sit with Curtis Hanson and eat dinner and like kick it for like two weeks And this for a little only was four seniors. Yeah, right and He was like You have anything booked after this. Right? And he was like, you have anything booked after this? I said, no.
他说，好吧，如果我增加你的戏份，你可以留下来。我说，去他的，我当然能留下来。我哪儿也不去。于是他们把我的合同延长到了整部电影。我们在那两个月里完善了那个角色。那真的很酷。事情就是这样开始的。太棒了。太棒了。太酷了。事情就是这样——
He was like, well, so if I extend your role, you can stay. I'm like, fuck yeah, I can stay. Ain't going nowhere. So they extended my contract to a run of Pitcher. And we developed that role over the course of two. That's really cool. And that's kind of how it started. That's amazing. That's amazing. That's so cool. And that's kinda how-
太棒了。事情就是这样开始的。太棒了。太酷了，你们是基于一个人，就像你们之间关于共同兴趣的对话一样，建立起了这个角色，这太——电影里最有趣的地方在于，埃米纳姆在电影结尾的那段说唱。
That's amazing. It started. That's amazing. That's so cool, you guys kinda built it off a person, like just like a dialogue that you were having with him about like a shared interest, like that's so- That's what's so funny in the movie, like Eminem has that rap at the end of the movie
他说，你上过私立学校之类的。如果你回到电影里，他说，你上过私立学校之类的。如果你回到过去，就像他说的，我们在前一周聊过天，互相开玩笑，你知道，M（埃米纳姆）是个了不起的家伙，也是个可爱的人。一旦你和他相处过，就会发现他很有趣，而且他总是在学习、倾听。他就像一块海绵。第二天我们到了片场，他说，嘿，我没理由不喜欢这家伙。虽然我们在戏里有矛盾，但没人知道我们的背景和历史，所以我们需要把它写进剧本里。柯蒂斯说，对，对，对，你说得对。然后到了对决的场景，对吧？
where he's like, you went to private school and all that shit. If you of the movie where he's like, you went to private school and all that shit. If you go back, like he's, we had a conversation a week before and we're talking shit and you know, M is just an amazing dude and a lovely human being. Once you spend time with him, it's just funny but he's always learning
我写好了我的韵脚，我说，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰。对，我们到了片场，埃米纳姆开始了他的说唱，他说，你上过私立学校。我说，我确实上过私立学校。他说，你父母婚姻很美满。我说，我父母的婚姻确实很美满。你这混蛋，你在说我。
and hearing and listening. Like he's like a fucking sponge. So we get to set the next day and he's like, yo, there's no reason why I don't like this dude. Like, yeah, we beefing, but nobody knows about our backstory and our history, so we need to put that in the script. So Curtis was like, yeah, yeah, yeah, you right, you right. So it comes the battle scene, right?
大人物。对，那很酷，很酷。哇。等等。等等，所以，《八英里》是你的第一部电影吗？那是我第一部电影。对。哇。对，那真的很酷。
And I write my rhyme, I'm like, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom. Right, we go to set and fucking Eminem starts his rap and he's like, you went to private school. I was like, I did go to private school. He's like, your parents have a real good marriage. I'm like, my parents do have a real good marriage. You motherfucker, you talking about me.
那是2001年，伙计。那是我第一部电影。不错的开始。那是我第一份工作。这不疯狂吗？我的意思是，那是一部非常大的电影。我知道。对。对。对。
Big man. Yeah, that's cool, that's cool. Wow. Now wait a second. Wait, so was, was Eight Mile your first movie? That was my very first movie. Yeah. Wow. Yeah, that's pretty cool.
我演过外百老汇的《逆风而行》，然后就去拍了《八英里》。你回过剧院吗？回过。嗯，我最后一次演舞台剧是2016年，和克里斯托弗·沃肯，还有地球上最了不起的人之一，山姆·洛克威尔和佐伊·卡赞。我们爱山姆。
That was 2001, man. That was my first movie. Nice start. That was my first job. Isn't that crazy? I mean, it was a first massive movie. I know. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
叫《斯波坎的手》。哦，对。我告诉你，如果你还没和克里斯·沃肯合作过，那就存点钱，制作一部戏，然后和克里斯·沃肯演一场戏。那混蛋太棒了。
I did, I did Up Against the Wind off Broadway and then went into Eight Mile. Have you been back to theater yet? Yeah, I did. Well, the last time I did theater was 2016 with Chris Walken and one of the most amazing human beings on earth, Sam Rockwell and Zoe Kazan. We love Sam.
那简直是演艺生涯的巅峰，每天晚上都能在舞台上看到他。哇。我敢说，我敢说。那真的很酷。多酷的经历啊。你知道，很多人说，演戏是对人类行为的研究，还有人类心理学之类的东西。你演过这么多不同的角色，扮演过这么多不同的人。在工作之外，你会发现自己会去揣摩别人的心思，或者分析别人的行为，或者分析工作之外的人类行为吗？我发现自己有时会不自觉地这样做。
Called Behanding in Spokane. Oh yeah. And I'll tell you what, if you haven't worked with Chris Walken, just save up some money, produce a play, and fucking do a play with Chris Walken. That motherfucker's amazing.
因为我会想，哦，那个人那样做是因为A，B，你明白我的意思吗？你会那样做吗？嗯，不，这是一个非常有趣的视角，也是个好问题，因为我一直都在这样做。但在这一代人中，人们被自己的不安全感所困扰，你真的没法问他们为什么做某事或怎么想，因为他们会立刻进入防御状态，因为他们甚至没想过自己为什么做那些事，为什么那样想。
Like that was the pinnacle of being able to do theater, to see him on stage every night. Wow. I bet, I bet. That's really cool. What a cool experience. You know, a lot of people say, you know,
为什么他们那样想。对，他们没想那么深。对，作为演员，对我来说，去理解人们，以及在你一天中发生了什么事让你刚才那样行动或反应，这真的很有趣。对，我喜欢这个，对。你只是问一些问题，比如，你为什么那样想？或者是什么让你那样想的？结果对方却说，哦，你真是个混蛋。
acting is the study of human behavior and there's human psychology and stuff like that. And you've done so many, so many different roles and so many played so many different people. Do you find yourself outside of work, kind of getting people's heads or analyzing people's behavior or analyzing the human behavior outside of a role? Like I find myself doing that probably to a fault sometimes
你知道的。对，因为我会把我的丈夫斯科蒂逼疯。我每天都会不停地问他，你好吗，你在做什么，你在想什么，发生了什么，你还好吗？就像试图钻进他心里，因为他会说，嘿，离我远点，我很好，我很好。你知道吗？
because I'm like, oh, that person acts like that because of A, B, you know what I mean? Do you do that? Well, no, that's a very interesting perspective and great question because I do that all the time. But in this generation, people are so thwarted with their own insecurities that you can't really ask questions
就像，我总是说，但你——是这样吗？你是个刨根问底的人，而他只是想安静一会儿。对，就像没什么不对劲。完全是这样。他真的很暴躁吗？他看起来真的很暴躁吗？
about why they do something or how they think, because they instantly go on the defensive, because they haven't even thought about why they do the things they do and why they think the way they do., why they think the way they do. Yeah, they don't think that deep. Yeah, and my thing is as an actor, it's really interesting to me to try and understand people
不，不，我只是想知道。但他会说，如果你一直问我，我就会生气。你明白我的意思吗？就像，一遍又一遍。听起来和我挺配的。如果你厌倦了斯科蒂，就把他送到我这儿来。我们在车里一起安静地待着。
and the knowledge and the aspect of what happened on the course of your day to make you act or react the way you did just now. Right, I love that, yeah. You just ask questions like, why do you think that way? Or what made you think that? And it's like, oh, you're just being an asshole.
我们会非常安静。就坐在那儿，闭上你的臭嘴。但我不知道，安东尼，你是不是也这样，安东尼，如果你像我一样，在一段关系中，无论是朋友、同事还是恋爱关系，无论是什么，我有时会过度分析别人，直到他们说，好了，别说了。对，我试着这样做，我只是问问题，给他们呼吸的空间，看看会发生什么。
And you know. Yeah, because I'll drive Scotty, my husband, crazy. I'll constantly ask him every day, how are you, what are you doing, what are you thinking about, what's going on, you all right? Like trying to get in there, because he's like, yeah, get out of my face, I'm fine, I'm fine. You know?
你知道，但出于某种原因，人们会认为你是个混蛋，他们会因为你试图理解他们而生气，因为他们自己从来没试着去理解自己。你知道，我越了解你，这段关系就越容易、越好。就像前几天我在聊天，我哥们说，你知道，你需要来洛杉矶，去参加派对，见见那些导演，这样人们才能看到你。我说，嘿，25年了，如果我非得去某某人的家里参加派对你才愿意和我合作，那去你的吧，伙计。你明白我的意思吗？
Like, and I'm always like, but you- Is that right? You're a digger, and he's just like, just let me be quiet. Yeah, like there's nothing wrong. Just completely. Is he really grouchy? Does he seem really grouchy?
就像你在这一行待得够久了，你知道那些人是怎么做事的。你明白我的意思吗？现在突然间我得去参加派对，还得给杰森口交。那些人是怎么做事的。现在这游戏是什么？这是什么新游戏？现在突然间我得去参加派对，还得给杰森口交。
No, no, I just want to know. But he goes, if you keep asking me, that's what I'm going to get upset. You know what I mean? Like, go over and over. It sounds like a great match for me. You ever get tired of Scotty, you send him over to me. We'll be quiet in the car together.
没错，杰森。对，留给我吧。但那确实是一句很短的台词，不是吗？杰森，别再把毒品放在你的丁丁上了。嗯，那大部分只是粉末。我没法在上面放一条线。那只是小升级。顺便说一句，你会听到一个有趣的，我这周在同一天给JB发了两次短信。两个人走到我面前说，嘿，我认识你哥们杰森。我以前和他一起聚会过。我以前住在威尼斯，还有另一个人，我和他在一个项目上合作过，我给JB发了短信，JB说，是的，我把很多人送进了康复中心。再见。他们1995年和杰森待了一周，他们就完了。他们彻底完了。等等，所以你，肖恩提到了，我的意思是，你拍了无数电影，你演过这么多不同类型的角色。
We'll be so quiet. Just sit over there and shut the fuck up. But I didn't know, Anthony, if you're like that, Anthony, where anything like me, where if it's in a relationship, whether it's a friend or a coworker or a romantic relationship, whatever it it is I just sometimes overanalyze people to death and they're just like okay stop talking. Yeah I try to and I just ask questions and give them space to breathe and just see what
我知道，太多了。还有你的外百老汇、百老汇，显然我们提到了茱莉亚学院，你做了所有这些事，然后你参演了《拆弹部队》，你参演了所有这些著名的电影，然后你被邀请加入漫威电影宇宙。那个过程是怎样的？那是漫威电影宇宙，特蕾西。她知道，那个不需要解释。我不知道，特蕾西是漫威的大粉丝吗？
comes out of that you know but for some reason people take that as you being an asshole and they get upset with you because you try and understand them and they've never tried to understand themselves. You know, and the more I understand you the easier and better this relationship will work out. Like I was having a conversation the other day and my boy was like, you know, you need to come to LA
她看起来不像。肖恩的妹妹，抱歉，安东尼，那是特蕾西。她真的很喜欢浪漫喜剧。对，没错。哦，好吧。那么，漫威电影宇宙。我们开始吧。我们开始吧。
and go to the parties and meet these directors so people can see you. And I'm like, yo, after 25 years if I got to go to a party at like so and so's house for you to want to work with me then fuck you, dude. You know what I mean?
那个电话是什么样的？那次谈话是什么样的？你是说，好的，还是说，啊，持怀疑态度？第一个，回答威尔的问题，第一个是《冬日战士》吗？那是第一个吗？那是第一个。对，因为我在……我看到了你，我看到了，
It's like you've been in this game long enough to where like you know the people that like are doing it in the way they doing it. You know what I mean? Now all of a sudden I got to come to parties and do blow off of Jason's dick for us. the people that like are doing it and the way they doing it. What's this game now? What is this new game? Now all of a sudden I gotta come to parties and do blow off of Jason's dick for us.
顺便说一句，我喜欢那部电影，我喜欢那部电影。我喜欢所有的电影，但我的意思是，当我看到你的时候，就像，什么鬼，这家伙太不可思议了，真是个令人难以置信的补充。什么鬼，我的意思是，这不断地，这个角色。你最喜欢的部分是什么，你知道那些翅膀。所以等等，所以等等，那是怎么展开的？那是怎么展开的？是吗？
Exactly, Jason. Yeah, leave that up to me. But it was a nice short line though, wasn't it? Jason, stop putting blow on your dick. Well, it's mostly just box. I can't really fit a line on there. It's just little upgrades. By the way, you'll hear a funny, I texted this to JB twice this week in the same day. Two
但是，是的，是的，接到电话是什么感觉，还有什么，天哪，那是什么？呃，你知道，它就像，你知道，就像一个，天哪，不，我知道，再多说点，不，我只是无法想象接到那样的电话。肖恩，肖恩，如果肖恩……如果斯科蒂知道肖恩要接到那个电话，他会先给他穿上尿布。就像一只小黑猩猩要尝到第一口冰淇淋一样。
people came up to me and go like, Hey, I know your buddy Jason. I used to party with him back in the day. I used to live in Venice and this other guy, I worked with them on a thing and I texted JB and JB goes, yeah, I put a lot of people into rehab. Bye. They spent a week with Jason in 1995 and they were screwed. They were done. Wait, so you do, Sean brought up, I mean you've done, I mean you've just done countless movies and you've done so many different kinds of characters.
该死，什么？在这个没有电梯的联排别墅里跑来跑去。只是在兴奋地跑。在地板上兴奋地跑。带着满肚子的安定药钻进电梯。还有一尿布的冰淇淋。不，但那一定是很酷的一天。就像，嘿，你想加入电影界最牛逼的东西吗？
I know, so many. And you're off Broadway, Broadway, obviously we mentioned Juilliard and you do all this stuff and then you were in Hurt Locker, like you've been in all these celebrated films, and then you get asked to become part of the MCU. And what was that process like? That's the Marvel Cinematic Universe, Tracy. She knows that, that's one we don't need to explain. I don't know, is Tracy a big Marvel fan?
这真的很有趣。不，确实。这真是很酷的一天，就像，嘿，你想加入电影界最牛逼的东西吗？不，那是一个非常酷的电话。你知道，但问题是，那不是林肯中心的话剧。所以就像你必须思考，好吧，我能，我能，我能，我能承受这个并继续追求那个吗？就像，当你得到机会时，你有时必须和自己以及你的团队进行某种战略性的职业发展对话，对吧？但那个剧本很棒，我肯定。不是说，你明白我的意思吗？嗯，但这就是漫威的问题。你不知道，你读不到剧本。
She doesn't strike me. Sean's sister, sorry, Anthony is Tracy. She really likes rom-coms. Right, yeah. Oh, okay. So, Marvel Cinematic Universe. Here we go. Here we go.
你什么都不知道。就像我和罗素兄弟开过会，而且……就像，我和罗素兄弟开过会，而且……这些人，他们太棒了！两个来自克利夫兰的兄弟！还有伟大的意大利血统！这两个家伙！我们的男孩真的在……我们爱我们的酸性开发！总之……
What was that call? What was that conversation? And were you like, yes, or were you like, ah, skeptical? Was the first one, to Will's question, was the first one Winter Soldier? Was that the first one? That was the first one. Yeah, because I saw you in the, I saw,
我们马上回来。好的。好的。总之。我们马上回来。回到节目。所以罗素兄弟打了电话，我们和乔还有安东尼很熟，乔什、JB和我。所以他们打电话给你，他们说，只说同意或不同意，不见剧本。对。对。
I love that movie by the way, I love that movie. And I love all of them, but I mean like, when I saw you it was like, what the, this guy's incredible, like what an unbelievable addition. What the fucking, I mean it's constantly, the character. What were your favorite parts, you know the wings. So wait, so wait, so how did that roll out? How did that roll? Yeah?
差不多，我们见面了，那是我经历过的最洛杉矶的事情。我们去了一家酒店，中间有一个艺术装饰风格的游泳池。到处都是那些老太太，带着她们的龙虾乳房躺在泳池边。你知道，我们点了午餐，她们就在那儿做饭。内特·摩尔和我大概是整个酒店里仅有的两个黑人。就像那是某种洛杉矶比佛利山庄的破事。每个人都戴着墨镜。
But yeah, yeah, how did it feel get the call and like what and oh my god, and what was it? Uh, you know it came together like, you know Like a what oh my god No, I know tell some more no, I just can't imagine getting a call like that. Sean, Sean, if Sean's... If Scotty knew who Sean was about to get the call, he'd put a diaper on him first. Like a little baby chimp about to get his first taste of ice cream.
所以，你知道，乔·罗素，他是那个说话的人，你知道。所以乔说，听着，安东尼，我们有一个剧本，我们有一个想法，你知道，我们有一个角色，我们想让你演。你感兴趣吗？我说，是的，我能读一下吗？他说，不。我能知道这个角色是谁吗？
Fucking what? Running around this townhouse with no elevator. Just doing zoomies. Zoomies on the floor. Tuck in the elevator with a belly full of Xanax. And a diaper full of ice cream. No, but that must have been a pretty cool day. Like, hey, you want to come and join the fucking biggest thing in the cinematic world?
不。所以我真的不知道我在演谁。那么是什么让你想说好的？乔的磁力。因为我知道加入漫威电影宇宙对我的职业生涯所做的贡献，就像被提名奥斯卡一样。对，没错。因为归根结底，如果你走上去，
It was really funny. No, it was. It's been a pretty cool day like hey you want to come and join the fucking biggest thing in the cinematic world No, it was it was a it was a really cool call to get You know, but the problem was it wasn't check off at the Lincoln at Lincoln Center So it was like you had you had to think okay Can I can I can I can I bear this and still pursue that right? Like there's a there's a strategic career, gross sort of conversation you have to have with yourself and your team perhaps at times when you get opportunity, right? But that script was phenomenal, I'm sure. It's not like, you know what I mean? Well, but that's the problem with Marvel. You don't know, you don't get to read the
我总是和我的朋友们这样做，归根结底，如果你走到普通人面前，问他们去年谁赢得了最佳男演员。不，不，不，没人知道。对，那只是我们。甚至不是普通人。问我们任何一个人去年谁赢得了最佳男演员。谁赢得了最佳男演员？我不知道。没人知道。甚至不是普通人。问我们任何一个人去年谁赢得了最佳男演员。
script. You don't get to know anything. Like I had a meeting with the Russo brothers and... Like, I had a meeting with the Russo brothers and... These guys, they're wonderful! Two brothers from Cleveland! But with the great Italian heritage! These two guys! Is our boys really getting... We love our acid development! Anyway...
谁赢得了最佳男演员？我不知道。阿德里安·布罗迪。我没法告诉你什么。阿德里安·布罗迪。走到普通人面前问他们谁，我们这个年纪的普通人，问他们谁演了洛奇或者谁做了这个。他们脑子里总会有那些标志性的
We'll be right back. Okay. Okay. Anyway. We'll be right back. And back to the show. So the Russo's called, we know Joe and Anthony real well, Josh, JB and I do. And so they call you and they're like, just say yes or no, sight unseen. Yeah. Yeah.
角色和时刻，而不是为了让你得到一座奖杯而进行的颁奖推广。当然，对，对。对，所以在这方面，这不需要动脑子。就像，就像我说的，就像，嘿，我们现在正在经营业内最大的生意。你想跳上这趟列车吗？我们要往那边走，你就像，
Pretty much, we meet, it was such, it was like the most L.A. shit I've ever experienced. We go to this hotel and it's like all like Art Stucco in a swimming pool in the middle. And it's like all these ladies, these old ladies with like their lobster
我有点想往那边走。当然愿意。但随后你让你的目光飘向安东尼·罗素，你会想，好吧，等等。这家伙一直盯着我看，一句话都没说。一个字都没说，他全程就盯着你看。我想知道是怎么回事。
titties laying out by the pool. You know, we ordered lunch and they're just like fucking cooking. And Nate Moore and I were like the only two black dudes in the whole hotel. Like it was some L.A. Beverly Hills shit. Everybody has their shades on.
安特（安东尼）会和你像个冷酷的疯子一样，而乔在说话吃三明治。他试图用这边的闪亮硬币分散你的注意力。别看我哥哥。我总是觉得乔抽出时间从玩梦幻足球中走出来，真正和你进行一次对话很有趣。那部分很有趣。别看他的手机，真正看着你和你说话一秒钟。我觉得自己是最特别的人。他就像《天才瑞普利》。他就像，哦，伙计，进展如何？
So, you know, Joe Russo, he's the talker, you know. So Joe goes, look Anthony, we have a script, we have an idea, you know, we have a character, and we'd like you to play it. Is that something you're interested in? And I was like, yeah, can I read it? He went, no. Can I know the character?
对，对，对，对，对。还有他的手机。所以发生了什么，那么在整个事情的哪个阶段，你终于开始了解你的角色是谁，比如他的名字是什么，他是什么，他住在哪里，然后真正阅读剧本，等等，等等？这离那还有多远？就在我上飞机去克利夫兰之前，
No. So I didn't know who I was playing, literally. So what made you want to say yeah? Joe's magnetism. Because I knew being in the MCU would like do for my career the same thing, you know, being nominated for an Oscar. Yeah, right. Because at the end of the day, if you go up,
因为我们在克利夫兰拍摄，大部分在克利夫兰，一些东西在亚特兰大，但我什么都没有。我只是像漫威，我喜欢这些电影。自从第一部《钢铁侠》以来，我就一直想参演这些电影。我说，我加入。我不知道那部电影是什么。
and I always do this with my friends, at the end of the day, if you go up to the average person and ask them who won best actor last year. No, no, no, nobody knows. Right, that's just us. Not even the average person. Ask any of us who won best actor last year. Who won best actor? I have no idea. Nobody knows. Not even the average person. Ask any of us who won best actor last year.
我只是想，因为我一直在接触他们，我在很久以前就让我的团队接触过他们，关于扮演黑豹的想法。就像成长过程中，黑豹是我最喜欢的漫画书之一，因为我最大的哥哥读了所有的漫画书，所以我总是，那就像卢克·凯奇和黑豹是我最喜欢的两个漫画偶像，还有超人，但他们是我最喜欢的两个黑人。
Who won best actor? I have no idea. Adrian Brody. I can't tell you what. Adrian Brody. Go up to the average person and ask them who, average person our age, ask them who played Rocky or who did this. They'll always have those iconic
我们一直都在追求并围绕着这个想法，在某个时间点他们必须拍黑豹。就像，你知道，给他们打电话，发邮件，发短信。我给凯文·费奇写信，去你的，黑豹。对吧？而且，所以我以为当他们联系我时，他们会说，你知道，你会演这个角色吗？我说，当然是黑豹。
characters and moments in their mind as opposed to an award push for you to get a statue. Sure, right, right. Right, so in that respect, it's a no-brainer. It's like, like I said, it's like, hey, we're running the biggest deal in the game right now. Do you want to jump on this train? We're going this way, and you're like,
但后来，当我拿到剧本时，我意识到那是山姆·威尔逊。一旦我开始阅读关于山姆·威尔逊的历史和背景，我意识到他在漫威电影宇宙中的重要性。就像斯坦·李打算让他成为什么样的人，以及他创造他是为了什么，这真的很棒，真的很深刻，真的触及了
I kind of want to go that way. Hell yeah. But then you let your eyes drift over to Anthony Russo, and you're like, well, hang on a second. This guy has not stopped staring at me, hasn't said a fucking word. Not a word, he just stares at you the whole time. And I want to know what the deal is.
当时美国黑人视角的想法。所以它是，你知道，他成为空降兵的一部分是战略性的，你知道，他是前军人是战略性的，他是来自哈莱姆区的骗子是战略性的，所有这些东西都被放进去，以社交化和模仿当时美国黑人文化是什么样的。
Ant is going to be a stone cold psycho with you while Joe's talking and eating a sandwich. He's trying to distract you with the shiny penny over here. Don't look at my brother. I always find it fun when Joe takes the time out from playing like fantasy football to actually have a conversation with you. That part's fun. Stop looking at his phone to actually look at you and talk to you for one second. I feel like the most special person. He's like the talented Mr. Ripley. He's like, oh man, so how's it going?
所以随着黑人文化的演变，山姆·威尔逊在漫威电影宇宙中也随之演变。所以你做了那个，所以你到了那里，你欣赏那个，然后你开始进入那个，然后你最终，你制作了，我不知道你拍了多少部电影，显然。大概七部。七部，对。大概六、七部。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And his phone. So what happens, so then at what stage of that whole thing do you get, do you finally kind of get keyed in on who your character is, like what his name is, what he is, where he lived, and then actually reading a script, et cetera, et cetera? Like how far down the road is that? Right before I got on a plane to go to Cleveland,
现在这将是我的第10部和第11部。第10部和第11部。我的意思是，嘿罗素兄弟，嘿，来个简短的客串怎么样？我知道，我们，杰森和我认识他们。当他们只是，他们执导了《发展受阻》的试播集，你想给我们打电话说，这是城里最老的两个……
because we shot that in Cleveland, mostly in Cleveland, some stuff in Atlanta, but I didn't have anything. I was just like Marvel, I loved the movies. I'd always wanted to be in the movies since the first Iron Man. I'm like, I'm down. I didn't know what the movie was.
我们认识乔和安东尼的时间和城里任何人一样长，对吧？杰森，城里谁认识那些家伙比我们更久？安东尼是终点，不要给乔发短信。那条短信会丢失在渗透中。这太不可思议了。首映式有几张不错的座位就太好了。对，那……
I just thought, because I had been approaching them, I had had my team approach them a long time before about the idea of playing Black Panther. Like growing up, Black Panther was one of my favorite comic books, cause my oldest brother read all the comic books, so I always, that was like Luke Cage and Black Panther were my two favorite comic icons, along with Superman, but they were my two favorite black dudes.
甚至在Regal电影院打个折也是我……你知道，我现在接受那个。你明白我的意思吗？但所以你做……所以这是你的第九部和第十部，或者第十部和第十一部。然后你是什么时候转型的，当你成为美国队长的时候？因为那是一个相当……那个衣钵是移交过来的。
And we had always gone after and circled the idea of, at some point in time they have to do Black Panther. Like, you know, call them, email them, text them. I write letters to Kevin Feige, fuck you, Black Panther. Right? And, so I thought when they hit me up, they were like, you know, would you play this role? I'm like, of course it's Black Panther.
那是什么时候？那是在《终局之战》结束时，这很奇怪，因为那是所有事情改变的时候。就像那是迪士尼收购漫威，迪士尼+成为现实的时候。在《终局之战》之后，一切都变成了漫威和漫威流媒体以及漫威电视以及迪士尼旗下所有这些不同实体的想法。所以因为那个，我对此非常高兴，因为你可以在八集系列剧中放入这么多内容，而不是一部一小时45分钟的电影，《猎鹰与冬兵》更多是关于山姆·威尔逊成为美国队长的想法。
But then, when I got the script, I realized it was Sam Wilson. And once I started reading the history and the background about Sam Wilson, I realized the importance of him in the MCU. Like what Stan Lee intended for him to be and what he created him for was really amazing and really profound and really spoke to the idea
并把所有其他破事抛在脑后。所以这就是我在《终局之战》之后做的。因为没人知道，就像在《终局之战》上，我不知道我要成为该死的美国队长。没人知道那破事。就像我那天在片场发现的时候。我不知道那个，但那个周日，周日我们在克里斯家看橄榄球，
of the perspective of the black American in America at that time. So it was, you know, him being a part of the airborne was strategic, you know, him being ex-military was strategic, him being a hustler from Harlem was strategic, all of those things were put in there to socialize and emulate what black culture was at that time in America.
我在克里斯家发现，周一早上我们要拍一个我成为美国队长的场景，因为他周三拿到了那些页面。不可能。你们开始一个项目时甚至拿不到剧本，哇。不，你得到一个上帝，你们开始一个项目时甚至拿不到剧本，哇。不，你得到一个剧本，但一旦你得到剧本，你就把它放下，每天你都会得到页面。
So as black culture evolved, so did Sam Wilson in the MCU. So you do that, so you get there and you appreciate that and you start getting into that and then you eventually, and you make, I don't know how many movies you're in, obviously. It's like seven. Seven, yeah. It was like six, seven.
哎哟。对，对，对。然后他们就像，嘿，你最好读读这些页面，因为我们要改变你的角色、你的生活、你的职业轨迹。就像，对，就像只是。好吧，所以就像，有一群超级书呆子坐在桌子旁，弄清楚所有这些不同的角色如何交织在一起，以及……
Now this would be my 10th and 11th. 10th and 11th. I mean, how about, hey Russos, hey, how about just a brief cameo? I know, we've been, Jason and I know them. When they were just, they directed the pilot of Rest of the Va, you want to just call us and say, these are two of the oldest...
你是什么意思，那是你想知道的？照照镜子，肖恩。一年计划，五年计划，十年计划，关于所有这些角色如何慢慢靠近彼此并交叉授粉，以及所有这些东西的智囊团在哪里，我想问，米老鼠什么时候进入所有这些东西？你知道这个想法是这一切的范围，最初的计划是第一个，你知道第一个，第一个10部电影，
We've known Joe and Anthony about as long as anybody in town, right? Jason, who knows those guys longer in town than us? Anthony is the end, do not text Joe. That text will be lost in the osmosis. It's unbelievable. Just a couple of nice seats for a premiere would be great. Yeah, that...
让那个弧线一直到终局之战。然后，你知道，之后的所有其他阶段，他们只是阶段性地构建它。所以你有阶段的开始、中间和结束，以及那个，你知道。我甚至不知道从哪里开始。我的意思是，你看到我从《钢铁侠》开始，就像那样，如果我只是从那里开始，
Even just a discount at Regal Cinema is what I... You know, I take that at this point. You know what I mean? But so you do... So this is your ninth and tenth or tenth and eleventh. And then when was it that you made the transit when you became Captain America? Because that's a pretty... That sort of mantle was handed over.
我，我会开始得到，你做《钢铁侠》一、二、三，然后你移动到哪里？好吧，看，这就是问题，好吧？嗯哼。我不认为你需要看所有的电影。就像，我不认为有些电影，比如《雷神》电影并没有真正，就像，
When was that? That was at the end of Endgame, which was weird because that's when all the shit changed. Like that's when Disney bought Marvel and Disney Plus became a thing. And after Endgame was when everything turned into this idea of Marvel and Marvel streaming and Marvel TV and all these different entities under the Disney umbrella. So because of that, which I was very happy about because you could put so much in an eight part series as opposed to an hour and 45 minute movie, the Falcon Winter Soldier show was more so about the idea of Sam Wilson becoming Captain America.
转化为宇宙。但那里可能有一些有用的信息影响其他东西，对吧？并不是真的，因为那是雷神自己的事情。那破事太遥远了，太不同了，因为他是个神。就像那破事，当你看到雷神进入漫威电影宇宙时，你从来没见过任何人去他的宇宙。
And leaving all the other shit behind. So that's what I did after Endgame. Because nobody knew, like on Endgame, I didn't know I was going to fucking be Captain America. Nobody knew that shit. Like when I found that out the day we were on set. I didn't know about that, but that Sunday, Sunday we were at Chris' house watching football,
对，对。所以蜘蛛侠不在，因为蜘蛛侠是索尼拥有的，蜘蛛侠在《内战》中进入了这个世界。所以，你不需要看任何17个版本的蜘蛛侠。所以，你真正需要看的是《钢铁侠》电影和《美国队长》电影。
and I found out at Chris' house that Monday morning we were shooting a scene where I became Captain America, because he had got those pages Wednesday. No way. You guys don't even get a script when you start a project, wow. No, you get a God, you guys don't even get a script when you start a project, wow. No, you get a script, but as soon as you get the script, you put it down and every day you get pages.
那些是给你主线的。那会把我带到《复仇者联盟》？所以《美国队长：第一复仇者》，以及所有的《钢铁侠》和《美国队长》电影会把你带到《终局之战》。杰米，我想我们需要做，你和我需要在你的新剧院做一个漫威电影宇宙电影节。
Oof. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And then they're like, hey, you better read these pages because we're about to change the trajectory of your character, your life, your career. Like, right, like just. Well, so like, is there like a group of like super dorks that are sitting around the table and figuring out how all of these different characters intertwine and like...
拜托，你什么时候在家？我肯定你们中有人家里有电影院。不，杰森有。我肯定你们三个家里都有电影院。我没有。杰森有。那不在他家里。那是它自己的建筑。现在听着。所以它字面上有一个不同的地址。嘿，哈米什。下一个问题。但所以你做所有那些事。你做，现在你是，然后你是，我不知道你怎么找到时间做所有这些其他事。
What do you mean that's what you wanna know? Look in the mirror, Sean. A one year plan, five year plan, 10 year plan for how all these characters slowly get closer to one another and cross pollinate and like where's the where's the think tank on all this stuff I want to ask the and when does Mickey Mouse come into all of this stuff? You know the idea is the the scope of it all the original plan was the the first you know the first, the first 10 movies,
更不用说我们有《烈火战车》第二季，七月底首映。我知道，这就像，七月。这是你正在制作的东西，威利？对，对，在Peacock上。那是七月底。第二季在那上面出来，这对Peacock来说是一个巨大的成功。
to have that arc all the way to end game. And then, you know, all the other phases after that, they just build it out phase by phase. So you have the beginning, the middle, and the end of the phase, and how that, you know. I wouldn't even know where to start. I mean, do you see what I start at Iron Man, and like that, if I just started there,
所以那个要出来了，你在推广那个。第二季超级有趣，安东尼太棒了，如果你还没看过，安东尼在里面太棒了，而且太搞笑了。这是一个好时光，这是一个好时光，很有趣。你是硬金属乐队的乐队成员？不，但不是一个坏的推销。不，爸爸。
I would, I'd start to get, you do the Iron Man one, two, and three, and then where do you move to? Well, see, this is the problem, all right? Mm-hmm. I don't think you need to watch all the movies. Like, I don't think some of the movies, like the Thor movies don't really, like,
我们只是在路上和你在一起，就像塞满巴士。不，爸爸。我们只是在路上和你在一起，就像塞满巴士。不，爸爸。他太忙于听游艇摇滚，没空看我们该死的节目。对，完全是。这是一个后世界末日的世界。它基本上是基于一个电子游戏。电子游戏《烈火战车》，在80年代和90年代，90年代和2000年代初很火。
translate into the universe. But there's probably some useful information there that affects other stuff, right? Not really, because that's Thor's own thing. That shit is so far out, it's so different, because he's a god. Like that shit, when you see Thor come into the MCU, you never see anybody go to his universe.
我们拿到了版权，并在主角约翰·多伊身后构建了这个世界，这是后世界末日，世界基本上正在分崩离析，但你看到约翰·多伊和其余的角色试图在其中穿梭，并弄清楚如何进入现在真实的世界，也就是世界各地这些有围墙的城市，社会和现实仍然存在，而不是墙外的战区。但安东尼，你知道，有这么多项目你正在，
Right, right. So Spider-Man wasn't around, because Spider-Man was owned by Sony, and Spider-Man came into the world on Civil War. So, you don't need to watch any 17 incarnations of Spider-Man. So, the movies you really need to watch are the Iron Man movies and the Captain America movies.
我的意思是，这令人震惊。对，或者，顺便说一句，这就像，安东尼，安东尼，安东尼，你还记得吗，就像，我们第一次在《烈火战车》上工作时我们会开会。我们有几次，就像，开发会议之类的，我会说，安东尼，你在哪儿？他说，我在沙特阿拉伯。我在船上。
Those are the ones that give you the through line. And that'll get me to Avengers? So Captain America, the first Avenger, and all the Iron Man and Captain America movies will get you to Endgame. Jamie, I think we need to do, you and I need to do an MCU film fest in your new theater.
他字面上就像，我在沙特阿拉伯的一艘船上。我说，你在说什么？好吧，那么这引发了显而易见的问题。让我们谈谈家庭生活。我们有一个家庭试图在所有这些中导航吗，还是你只是一个摇滚单身汉，你可以带着你的节目上路？不，我意识到的一件事是作为一个，
Please, when are you home? I'm sure one of y'all got a movie theater in y'all house. No, Jason does. I'm sure all three of you have movie theaters in here. I do not. Jason does. It's not in his house. It's its own building. Now listen. So it literally has a different address. Hey, Hamish. Next question. But so you do all that stuff. You do, and now you're, and then you're, I don't know how you find the time to do all this other stuff.
就像我是一个坚定的信徒，我认为，就像我喜欢工作。对，显然。我觉得我工作就是我的快乐。我和你一样。我喜欢保持忙碌。就像，那只是我的快乐。可悲的是，大多数时候当你离开
Not to mention the fact that we've got Twisted Metal Season Two, which is premieres end of July. I know, this is like, July. This is the thing you're producing, Willie? Yeah, yeah, on Peacock's. That's end of July. Season Two comes out on that, which is a huge hit for Peacock.
四五个月时，关系并不真正适合那个。我所有的空闲时间和所有空虚的大脑空间都给了我的孩子们。我有四个儿子和四个小男孩，伙计。他们太有趣、太不同、太有操纵性，同时又是小混蛋。所以就像，你知道，你必须，就像我拥有的每一刻空闲时间都是爱上我男孩的时刻。
So that's coming out, you're promoting that. Second season's super fun, Anthony's so good, if you haven't seen it, Anthony is so good in it, and so funny. It's a good time, it's a good time, it's fun. You're a band member in a hard metal band? No, but not a bad pitch. No, dad.
你知道吗？所以我真的没有空间。他们能和你一起参加其中一些事情吗？嗯，他们会。他们会出来探望，但问题是我必须记住他们有自己的生活，完全就像，你知道，现在我在布达佩斯，我的男孩们为了两个半月的夏天工作了整个学年，完全就像，对，所以我说去你的营地，去你的朋友？
We're just on the road with you, it's like stuffing the bus. No, dad. We're just on the road with you, it's like stuffing the bus. No, dad. He's too busy listening to yacht rock to watch our fucking show. Yeah, totally. It's a post-apocalyptic world. It's basically based on a video game. The video game Twisted Metal, which was big in the 80s and 90s, 90s and early 2000s.
对，你很有趣，你来到正确的，正确的酒店房间，当我在工作时，哦，对。我看到他们。对，我在你睡觉前能看到你。完全一样的问题。那会是，我会讨厌那个。对，对。所以这是一个，你知道。嗯，什么酒店？哪个酒店？
We got the property and built out this world behind the lead character John Doe, and it's the post-apocalypse and the world is basically falling apart, but you see John Doe and the rest of the characters trying to maneuver through it and figure out how to get inside what is now the real world, which are these walled- in cities all over the world where society and reality still exist instead of the war zone that's outside the walls. But Anthony, you know, there's so many projects that you're,
谈判。这取决于，布达佩斯酒店。哟，我的男孩们，他们喜欢好的客房服务，伙计。他们该死的鸡翅是。鸡柳，破事。还有工艺服务。鸡柳。我敢打赌你的漫威提供好的客房服务，伙计。他们该死的鸡翅是。鸡柳，破事。鸡柳。我敢打赌漫威在片场也提供不错的工艺服务。好的零食？
I mean, it's mind blowing. Yeah, or, by the way, it would be like, Anthony, Anthony, Anthony, do you remember, like, we would have meetings when we were first working on Twisted Metal. We had a couple, like, development meetings or something, and I'd be like, Anthony, where are you? And he's like, I'm in Saudi Arabia. I'm on a boat.
哟，我们的工艺服务太疯狂了，伙计。我会告诉你。然后你也可以去唐尼的营地，得到一点额外的东西。然后它更疯狂。但就像有一天，我溜了过去。嗯，你会从唐尼的营地得到你的纤维。哦，当然，如果你是麸质
And he literally was like, I'm on a boat in Saudi Arabia. And I'm like, what are you talking about? All right, so then this prompts the obvious question. Let's talk about domestic life. Do we have a family that we're trying to navigate through all this, or are you just a rockin' single and you just can take your show on the road? No, the one thing I realize is being a,
走过去，当我们有披萨车时，我走到他的保安那里，保安真是个酷家伙，我说，看，伙计，我走到披萨车那里，他们都坐在那里聊天，我说，我不坐在那里和那些混蛋聊天，我想做披萨，所以我走到披萨伙计那里，开始在车上做披萨，对吧？所以我做了这个很棒的，美味的，我的意思是，厨师之吻披萨，对吧？所以我切了一块，我走到唐尼保安那里，我说，哟，伙计，这是一片披萨。就像，我知道你度过了漫长的一天，
like I'm a firm believer that I think, like I love to work. Yeah, clearly. I feel like me working is my happiness. I'm with you. I love to stay busy. It's like, that's just my joy. And sadly to say that most of the times when you're gone
所以我只是想介绍一下自己。我们还没见过面，我叫安东尼，见到你真好。他说，哦，见到你真好。所以两天后，我说，我想溜进罗伯特该死的基地营。因为里面有空调。对。
for four and five months at a time, relationships don't really fit into that. All of my free time and all of my empty brain space goes to my kids. I have four sons and four little boys, dude. They are so interesting and different and manipulative and just little assholes at the same time. So it's like, you know, you have to, like every free moment I have is a moment to fall in love with my boys.
对。对。对。对。你有什么主意之类的吗？我走进我的拖车，我没有冰。我说，我知道谁有该死的冰，对吧？所以我溜到罗伯特的基地营。
You know? So I don't really have space. Are they able to come with you on some of these things? Well, they do. They'll come out and visit, but the problem is I have to remember that they have their own life exactly You know like now I'm in Budapest and my boys have worked all school year for two and a half months of summer exactly Yeah, so do I say fuck your camps fuck your friends?
我走到保安那里。我说，哟，怎么了？他说，安东尼，进展如何？他说，那是个很棒的披萨，谢谢。我说，嘿，你介意我进去吗，伙计？他说，安东尼，进展如何？他说，那是个很棒的披萨，谢谢。我说，嘿，你介意我进去一下吗？他说，不，请便。我偷了他所有该死的冰。事情就是这样运作的，孩子。
Yeah, you're fun you come to the right right hotel room while I'm at work Oh, right. I see them. Yeah, I get to see you right before you go to bed. Same exact problem. That would be, I would hate that. Yeah, right. So it's a, you know. Well, what hotel? Which hotel?
事情就是这样运作的。对。没错，这就是你认识的人，这就是你认识的人。这就是你认识的人。这根杆子上没有小人。好吧，听着伙计，我们占用了你太多时间。你在那边，你在工作，你在玩得开心，
Negotiate. It depends, the Budapest Hotel. Yo, my boys, they love a good room service, boy. They're fucking chicken wings are. The chicken tenders, shit. And craft service. The chicken tenders. I bet your Marvel puts up a good room service, boy. They're fucking chicken wings are. The chicken tenders, shit. The chicken tenders. I bet you Marvel puts up a nice craft service on set too. Good snacks?
你可能在你的周末，我们正在侵占它。对，你出现真是太好了。你真是太好了。安东尼，和你聊天总是很棒。再次，你是我认识的最忙的人，你是一个超级有才华的人。太令人印象深刻了。如果你还没看过《烈火战车》，
Yo, our crafty is crazy, dude. I'll tell you. And then you can go over to Downey's Camp too and get a little something extra. And then it's crazy-er. But like one day, I snuck over. Well, you'll get your fiber in Downey's Camp. Oh sure, if you're gluten
嘿，我们的手艺真是绝了，伙计。我跟你说，你还可以去唐尼的营地，额外弄点好东西，那就更疯狂了。有一天，我偷偷溜过去。好吧，你在唐尼的营地能补充到纤维。哦，当然，如果你是麸质过敏的话
Step over there when we were when he had the pizza truck I went up to his security securities real cool guy I was like look man I went over to the pizza truck and all them was sitting in there talking I'm like I don't sit in there talk to them motherfuckers I want to make pizza so I go over with the pizza guys and start making pizza on the truck right so I made this Dope delish I mean chefs kiss pizza, right so I cut a piece dope, delicious, I mean, chef's kiss pizza, right? So I cut a piece off, and I go over to Downey Security Goal, and I'm like, yo, man, here's a slice of pizza. Like, I know you've had a long day,
当时他有披萨车，我走过去找他的保安，那人真的很酷。我说，嘿，伙计，我去了披萨车那边，他们都在那儿坐着聊天，我说我才不跟那帮混蛋坐着聊天呢，我想做披萨。于是我就去披萨车那边开始做披萨，我做了一个超棒、超美味，简直是厨神级别的披萨。我切了一块，走到唐尼的保安那儿，我说，嘿，伙计，给你一块披萨。我知道你今天辛苦了，
so I just wanted to introduce myself. We haven't met, my name's Anthony, it's so great to meet you. He's like, oh, nice to meet you. So two days later, I'm like, I want to sneak in Robert's fucking base camp. Because he has air conditioning in it. Yeah.
所以我只是想自我介绍一下。我们还没见过面，我叫安东尼，很高兴见到你。他说，哦，很高兴见到你。所以两天后，我想，我要溜进罗伯特的基地营地。因为他那儿有空调。没错。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You got an idea or something? I go in my trailer, I don't have ice. I'm like, I know who has fucking ice, right? So I sneak over to Robert's base camp.
是啊。是啊。是啊。是啊。你有什么主意吗？我回到我的拖车里，没有冰块。我想，我知道谁有冰块，对吧？所以我溜进了罗伯特的基地营地。
I go to the security guard. I was like, yo, what's up? And he's like, Anthony, how's it going? He's like, that was a great pizza, thanks. I was like, hey, you mind if I go in up man? He's like, Anthony, how's it going? He's like, that was a great pizza, thanks. I was like, hey, you mind if I go in right quick? He's like, no, go right ahead. I stole all his fucking ice. That's how it works, kid.
我去找保安。我说，嘿，怎么样？他说，安东尼，你好吗？他说，那披萨真棒，谢谢。我说，嘿，你介意我进去一下吗？他说，安东尼，你好吗？他说，那披萨真棒，谢谢。我说，嘿，你介意我进去一下吗？他说，不，请便。我偷了他所有的冰块。这就是门道，孩子。
That's how it works. Yeah. That's right, it's who you know, it's who you know. It's who you know. There's no little man on this pole. Well, listen man, we've taken up too much of your time. You're over there, you're working, you're having a good time,
这就是门道。没错。就是这样，关键在于你认识谁，关键在于你认识谁。关键在于你认识谁。这根杆子上可没有小矮人。好吧，听着，伙计，我们占用你太多时间了。你在那边工作，玩得很开心，
you're probably in your weekend and we're eating into it. Yeah, that's really nice of you to show up. Very nice of you. Anthony, it's always awesome to talk to you. Again, you're the busiest dude I know, and you're such a super talented dude. So impressive. And if you haven't seen Twisted Metal,
你可能正在过周末，而我们却在占用你的时间。是啊，你能来真是太好了。非常感谢你。安东尼，和你聊天总是很棒。再说一次，你是我认识的最忙的人，而且你非常有才华。太令人印象深刻了。如果你还没看过《烈火战车》，
please see Twisted Metal Season Two on July 31st on Peacock. Like I said, Anthony's amazing in it. And then your new show coming out next year on Apple, which 12, 12, 12, which is gonna be amazing. And more Avengers and more all of it. And dude, Anthony. Keep it coming, we love it. Keep it coming, continued success, dude.
请在7月31日关注Peacock平台上的《烈火战车》第二季。就像我说的，安东尼在里面的表现太棒了。还有你明年在Apple上推出的新剧《12, 12, 12》，那一定会非常精彩。还有更多的《复仇者联盟》以及所有其他作品。伙计，安东尼，继续保持，我们很喜欢。继续加油，祝你事业蒸蒸日上，伙计。
You're a great dude. Thanks a lot, man, appreciate it. Sean, I'm gonna come check you when I get back to London. Your mind will be loved. I love it, I love it, thank you. I feel like you like Aperol spritz and shit, so we can have like an Aperol spritz. I'll have it, I'll have anything with a spritz in it. I would love that Anthony, it'd be great to see you too.
你真是个好人。太感谢了，伙计，我很感激。肖恩，等我回伦敦时我会去找你。你的心意我会铭记的。我喜欢，我喜欢，谢谢你。我觉得你喜欢阿佩罗橙光之类的东西，所以我们可以喝杯阿佩罗橙光。我会喝的，任何带气泡的酒我都喝。我很乐意，安东尼，能见到你也很棒。
Yeah, so come on down, I would love it, I'd be so honored. Definitely, will do. Great to see you. Awesome, thank you, thanks Anthony. Thanks a lot guys. Thank Great to see you. Awesome, thank you. Thanks, Anthony. Thanks a lot, guys. Nice to see you. Nice to see you, pal. See you, buddy. Oh, Sean, hey Sean, great job.
是啊，一定要来，我会很高兴的，我会感到非常荣幸。一定，我会的。很高兴见到你。太棒了，谢谢，谢谢安东尼。非常感谢你们。太棒了，很高兴见到你。太棒了，谢谢。谢谢，安东尼。非常感谢，伙计们。很高兴见到你们。很高兴见到你，老兄。再见，伙计。哦，肖恩，嘿肖恩，干得好。
Great job. Thank you, thank you. You know Sean's been working with a tutor, an interview tutor? Yeah, mm-hmm, thank you. Yeah, it's subtle, but it's much better. Thank you, I mean, I'm billing her three ways. So how could he?
干得好。谢谢，谢谢。你知道肖恩一直在请导师辅导吗，面试导师？是的，嗯哼，谢谢。是的，虽然很微妙，但确实好多了。谢谢，我是说，我付给她三倍的钱。所以他怎么可能学不会呢？
He's the only nominated interviewer that we've got. There's always room to improve, he said to me in a text. Were you not on that? Yeah. No. How great is Anthony, right? Yeah, he's great. I've never met him.
他是我们这里唯一获得提名的面试官。总有改进的空间，他在短信里对我这么说。你当时没在那个群里吗？是的。没有。安东尼多棒啊，对吧？是的，他很棒。我从没见过他。
Never seen an interview with him. And that was awesome. Yeah, he's really cool. He's such a great dude. And when you look at his credits, it's so unbelievably impressive. Not just the volume, but all the different kinds of characters he's played.
从没看过他的采访。那真是太棒了。是的，他真的很酷。他真是个好人。当你查看他的作品列表时，简直令人难以置信。不仅是数量多，而且他扮演的角色种类繁多。
I'd love to see him on stage too. I bet he's a beast. Incredible on stage. And you see that like, you see, remember he said early on, he was like, well, you know, you want to come come out you want to do too many different things Because you don't want people right that you're all over the place. I'm like, dude Yeah, I mean he did every he's covered every corner. Yeah, I know and he's got like 17 things coming out soon
我也很想看他在舞台上的表演。我敢打赌他是个猛兽。在舞台上不可思议。你看到了吗，记得他早些时候说的吗，他说，嗯，你知道，你不想做太多不同的事情，因为你不想让人们觉得你什么都做。我说，伙计，是的，我是说他做了所有事情，他涵盖了每一个领域。是的，我知道，而且他很快就有17部作品要上映了。
I know like there was there was one year There was one year I think where he had like eight movies in theaters at the same time. Are you kidding me? No. Crazy. Oh my God, the promotional work on that must have been a nightmare. That's the first thing you think of. All the stories you've got to come up with.
我知道，好像有一年，我想有一年他同时有八部电影在影院上映。你在开玩笑吗？没有。太疯狂了。天哪，那宣传工作一定是一场噩梦。那是你首先想到的。你必须编造出所有的故事。
Oh God. How about this anecdote? You immediately think about the junket. Yeah. That's the first thing you think of. You have to think of like so many different ways on that junket to say... Like what? Good.
天哪。这个轶事怎么样？你立刻就会想到媒体见面会。是的。那是你首先想到的。在那个见面会上，你必须想出很多不同的方式来说……比如什么？好。
No, no, no. Work on it a little bit more. Come back to us, Will. That was just a straight up... You got another one? Well, no. You know what you ought to do next time you're trapped in the elevator? Think of some good vibes.
不，不，不。再多下点功夫。回来找我们，威尔。那只是一个直接的……你还有别的吗？嗯，没有。你知道下次被困在电梯里该做什么吗？想点好心情。
Yeah. And just put a chalkboard in there, you know what you ought to do next time you're trapped in the elevator thinking some good vibes? Yeah. And just put a chalkboard in there, you know what I mean? Is there a new dad joke you've got for us today? We haven't had a dad joke today, I'd really like one. I did have, did I do the, what did the pirate say when he turned 80? Did I do that one already?
是的。在里面放块黑板，你知道下次被困在电梯里该做什么吗？想点好心情。是的。在里面放块黑板，你明白我的意思吗？你今天有什么新的冷笑话要讲给我们听吗？我们今天还没听过冷笑话，我真的很想听一个。我确实有一个，我讲过那个“海盗80岁时说了什么”吗？我已经讲过那个了吗？
No, uh-uh. What did the pirate say when he turned 80? Well, what? I madey., matey. Hi, matey. That really got him. I just love them so much, but I love them coming out of Sean's face. I know.
没有，嗯嗯。海盗80岁时说了什么？嗯，什么？我老了，伙计（I madey）。嘿，伙计。那真的让他笑了。我太喜欢它们了，但我更喜欢从肖恩嘴里说出来。我知道。
You know? Because he's just like, I'm half laughing already when I'm around him. I just put the grin on my face. What did the pirates say after they played the game? They said, I'm going to be the best player in the world. I'm going to be the best player in the world. I'm going to be the best player in the world. I'm going to be the best player in the world.
你知道吗？因为我只要在他身边，就已经笑了一半了。我脸上就会露出笑容。海盗玩完游戏后说了什么？他们说，我要成为世界上最好的玩家。我要成为世界上最好的玩家。我要成为世界上最好的玩家。我要成为世界上最好的玩家。
I'm going to be the best player in the world. I'm going to be the best player in the world. I'm going to be the best player in the world. I'm going to be the best player in the world. I'm going to be the best player in the world. I'm going to be the best he's just like, I'm half laughing already when I'm around him. He puts a grin on my face. What did the pirate say after they plundered the other boat? What? Bye matey! It's so fun hanging out with you guys. Bye gang! Rob Armjarf and Bennett Barbico. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我要成为世界上最好的玩家。我要成为世界上最好的玩家。我要成为世界上最好的玩家。我要成为世界上最好的玩家。我要成为世界上最好的玩家。我要成为最好的，我只要在他身边，就已经笑了一半了。他让我脸上露出笑容。海盗抢劫完另一艘船后说了什么？什么？再见，伙计！和你们在一起太有趣了。再见，伙计们！罗伯·阿姆贾夫和贝内特·巴比科。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。